so elon musk has officially terminated
the twitter buyout that's it ladies and
gentlemen it's all over your hopes and
dreams your savor savior he has not he
is not a saver he has not come through
for you but uh some people are arguing
that elon musk's latest move
canceling the deal is actually 40 chess
we've actually known for some time
it's been widely speculated i should say
that elon was trying to get a better
deal better bang for his buck
this could be
him challenging twitter arguing that
it's a breach of contract because the
spam bots but the ceo prague agrawal
already said he's going to war to make
sure this deal happens
elon backs out now a lot of people are
like oh elon can't do that because then
he'll get sued and he owes a billion
dollars that's not how it works here's
how it works twitter can go to war they
can go to the courts and they can try
and force elon musk to pay out the
billion dollars or buy the company or
they can go to him and settle and this
means elon musk could get a settlement
agreement
that is him offering to buy the company
at a lower amount so we will see in
other news joe biden accidentally read
teleprompter instructions and the media
is trying to claim it was not a mistake
and the white house has come out and
said no no it was completely legit and
they've done this before they are
gaslighting us the sad thing is you and
i obviously we don't fall for it
but so many people do
so it's a friday night we have all that
to talk about and then obviously you
guys know the very very serious news
you know the assassination of shinzo abe
the longest-serving prime minister in
japan very popular we have the media
already smearing him right when the dude
dies brutal man i can't stand the press
so we'll talk about all of that before
we get started my friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member
to support our work we have a bunch of
new shows we're going to be launching
soon a lot of conversations a lot of
production stuff and well we're going to
launch new shows so that you as members
will have a ton of new content a more
bang for your buck
but for those of you that want to just
support our efforts in building culture
and making the content becoming a member
is the best way to do it you'll also get
access to the tim cast irl after hours
show we're actually gonna be like
renaming things making it easier to
navigate making it easier to sign up in
the first place so we're probably going
to give the after show we do a show and
probably call it irl after show or
something like that tales from the
inverted world we are expanding we're
quadrupling the length of episodes
making it an exclusive for the website
and we've got a couple other shows we're
talking self-help with a psychologist
we're talking uh potential shows on
survival all this really awesome stuff
and it's thanks to all of you who are
members so go to timcast.com sign up
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and uh without further ado joining us
today to discuss all of this and more is
the one and only hotep jesus hey what's
up man thank you for having me yeah
how's it going how are you um i'm doing
absolutely fantastic man i've been on
fire for the pa this whole year has been
a great year for me um things are going
really well i'm doing great man
what do you what do you do for those
that are not familiar with your work i
don't do anything i just try to uh
you know do anything i don't do anything
do anything mind my business i just mind
my own business you know now you got a
youtube channel right and
uh
i uh give my thoughts on matters that
are happening across america i try not
to do the whole international thing
because it's not my country you know i
stick to
you know my backyard and i talk about uh
you know my observations what do i see
and and maybe a couple of solutions
uh you know for example women uh
mandating the hijab for women this
summer i think would be a good start um
and other crazy ideas
i tweeted uh i said
it's going to get me in trouble oh boy i
said on twitter the good thing uh is
that when the guns the good thing is
when the guns are finally banned the
women won't be able to fight back
against the fascists
i'm sorry the handmaidens won't be able
to fight back against the fascists and
so there'll be four
i'll just leave it there
oh no anyway well you know what happens
with handmaiden so i was making a spicy
joke it's on twitter i'm surprised i
don't get banned
but
we'll we'll maybe talk about it uh we
also have joining us once again is mary
morgan you do i'm back
i'm mary i co-host pop culture crisis
we're a live show on youtube we talk
about more light-hearted topics
celebrity drama movies all the
entertainment news so i strongly
encourage you to go subscribe and uh
we're going live again on monday you can
shoot money at us with your super chats
yeah when you so when you super chat pop
culture crisis there are money guns that
fire money very distracting and then
yeah it's meant to be like silly and fun
and then there's like if if too much
money is given then they go crazy and
fire for like 30 seconds or something oh
that's sick yeah there's like sirens go
off oh
yeah silly parties oh that's amazing
yeah we got ian
hi everyone we were listening to guns
and roses before the show and then
flipped over to uh audio slave i feel
like i'm in my element man
audio it's like getting a good massage
yeah mental massage
listen to slash on the lead guitar it
just takes me takes me back to being
like 13 years old hanging out with my
friends and realizing what music can
actually be like i mentioned it's like a
drug like it can affect your body
physiologically like a drug yes that is
true
it happened to me once tell me about it
i was working in the mortgage industry
and me and my boss weren't getting along
too long and i was playing eminem's
first album uh i wish i had a behind big
enough for the whole world to kiss
and uh i was playing that song on repeat
the whole way to work well when i got to
work let's just say i wasn't me i was
somebody different and i almost got
fired boy
so yes music can yes i was like wait no
more eminem before i could ever
gotta choose something maybe some church
music or something yeah we
yeah i was telling tim that that is one
of my that guns and roses song we were
listening to sweet childhood mine was on
my face today i got my first spot on
terrestrial radio with wilford reilly he
was uh hosting a show for one of his
good friends in the southeastern area
and i got a few segments in for him it's
a lot of fun we were talking about
hunter biden we talked about all the
stuff we typically talk about on this
show and i had a great time not sure if
you can find that online but it was a
good time really recommend following
wilfred if you don't already at
wildebeest 6 30 on twitter super cool
speaking of music and hunter biden oh
yeah um i think he should listen to uh
biggie's second album there's uh one on
there called the ten crack commandments
oh boy he would know all about benefit
from that
yeah all right let's jump into this
first story we got this from the daily
mail elon musk tells twitter he is
terminating his 44 billion dollar
takeover because the company misled him
on the number of spam bots on site as
stocks plunge six percent
i just gotta say ellen musk is right uh
look
when twitter came out and said it was
like what did they say five percent or
something yeah
a whole bunch of there was there were
several different independent
assessments that they were like no way
that's way wrong
five percent is like the number of real
accounts right no right i i saw a tweet
that i think was from paul scalise that
was saying uh there's like at most a
hundred thousand people on twitter i
honestly may be true yeah i obviously i
think it's i think it's maybe several
million maybe tens of millions but not
hundreds of millions i think it's all
one big i'd go with tens of millions
tens of millions yeah and you can you
know you know you know you know what
makes me think so
donald trump on truth social has 3.4
million and you look at the engagement
it's comparable
he posts a truth and he gets you know
thousands of comments it was the same
when he was on twitter i'm like how
could it be the engagement stays the
same but the total following count is
way lower most people don't care
now the question is
is elon musk playing 4d chess
because look he's got a contract right
he can't just back out right people
people don't get this
i see these lefties posting like oh
elon's gonna have to pay a billion
dollars now and i'm like oh cause that's
how lawsuits work right these people
have clearly never dealt with a legal
system
someone could could smash into your car
and it could be their fault and you
could be in court for years trying to
figure that stuff out so what usually
happens is your lawyer says just saddle
with him it's so much easier make it go
away the judges often will tell you find
a settlement agreement so i've had to
deal with this stuff the judge will say
yeah we can go to court we can litigate
all this stuff i'm instructing you to to
attempt a settlement first
so what i think is going to happen for
one let's just be simple don't get your
hopes up elon might just be backing out
maybe he wasn't serious
or maybe start what was that i knew it
from the start
had a bad feeling about it yes
but maybe
we've been hearing for months that elon
wanted uh a better offer a better deal
yeah because the stock had been going
down for twitter so it was like it was
worth less and less and less
so he probably went to his financiers
and they were like you can get it
cheaper
just give let it stew
the stock's gonna kind of gonna drop
because the market
you can back away and twitter will still
save money by just agreeing to lower
terms as opposed to going to court and
trying to win a billion dollars from you
so that could be it because the ceo said
he's going to war to make sure this deal
goes through we had a will chamberlain
tweeted that elon's going to buy this
whether he wants to or not
yeah i was just referencing i was
referencing that same tweet by will he
he specified that twitter would likely
argue that one elon wasn't entitled to
the information he wanted which was like
how many bots are on the platform he
wasn't entitled and number two that if
he wasn't titled the failure to provide
the information was not a material
breach because the information isn't
relevant to any of the reps or
warranties in the agreement
this is from will chamberlain
but that's what makes me think it's it's
it's
potentially 40 chess
i don't want to come out and be like oh
elon's so smart he's going to get them
now the dude may have just screwed up
yeah you know but
there's no way elon
he planned this out right he he he
released it on what 420
like this dude was like
calculating what he was doing yeah or
maybe not do you think he's always
playing the long game
i think people are comforted by thinking
elon has a plan you don't become a
billionaire
playing a long game yeah and it's not
just it's not just that it's not hard to
play the long game right like we here at
tim cast we're playing the long game you
know what i mean yeah like i've got my
vision board that every day we wake up
and ian and i will put pictures of
celebrities
no no but but you know we have a
generalized thought process of like
today we do this and if this works the
next day we do this and if this works
the next day we do this
so i have to imagine
when he was negotiating this contract he
had lawyers like he thought about what
could happen and this is not out of the
question this is one of the scenarios he
should have expected to occur
so i think whether he buys it or not i
think he knows what he's doing yeah yeah
you know my thing my trouble is with the
headline i don't want to say it's
misleading but it's really missing the
real problem with the deal
and we've all experienced this when the
whole elon situation was announced
did you get a huge uh explosion
engagement that's right okay so and and
the left and celebrities lost a ton of
engagement um
hundreds it's it's
it was crazy
it was the day after the deal was
finalized right all of a sudden
prominent left-wing accounts lost tens
of thousands to hundreds of thousands of
followers
and people associated with the right
libertarians or you know the the
politically homeless what are they
called post liberal yeah saw huge gains
i gained a hundred thousand followers in
three days
people were getting unbanned right
something crazy happened yeah so my
theory is uh the employees
abandoned the project
and that's in
part of the deal was as any with merger
right you have to keep your staff
on staff right because otherwise you're
buying the company the staff is a huge
part of these the people that run the
thing
every day right
so i'm looking at the situation and i'm
like uh
maybe that's the big problem i don't
think it's the bots like i think elon
understands the bot game and i don't
think that's a deal breaker like you
know there's bots when you're dealing
with social media right
i think it's the the employees because
so many employees had a mass exodus and
then i don't know what happened but i
think they turned the algorithm back on
because the engagement dropped again for
us but i think
whoever it is up there they're like okay
elon's gonna buy this thing let's hide
the algo right right
and then like the deal is off and it's
like i turn the algo back on and i think
what you're saying attributes to that is
like the left huge amount of engagement
everybody else engagement drops right
and so the algo favors that left wing
opinion i'm guessing but that's what i
think the deal really came what if it's
what if it's actually a bit more
nefarious get a little conspiratorial
what if elon fully intended to buy the
platform
and then we've talked about this before
alex berenson who was banned do you know
him
he was covering a ton of the vaccine
stuff and he got he skeptical yeah he
got banned
filed a lawsuit won and was reinstated
and he said he's investigating
government involvement in twitter
censorship
what if elon was like hey i'm gonna buy
this platform guys and then he goes up
to the meeting and then twitter says as
part of our disclosure process here's
our national security letter and he went
oh crap
and you can't say anything about it
because you got an nda yeah and now he's
like i don't want to buy this right well
look at what jack was saying when he was
telling people about dealing with boards
and all of that type of situations
dealing with vcs there's a lot jack was
saying um
between the lines you kind of had to
read when i don't know if you watched it
but he was arguing with some people
jack dorsey jack dorsey yeah he's
arguing with some people in the threads
and he was kind of saying like there's
some shaky things going on with twitter
with the twitter and the government
uh he didn't allude to the government
you know i would say it's more like ngos
lizard people
yeah something something more realistic
like that yeah more realistic
elon shows up to the meeting and he's
like okay so can we finalize these
contracts and they're like uh yes but
one minute zorthon elan
we control twitter
actually i've been getting sworn in as
the president i'm sorry i shouldn't have
said zorthon he goes hillary
that's a joke that's funny but but is
let's talk about the money is twitter a
good investment to me i don't see
twitter as being a good money player i
think it's a good power play right
because now you control this medium of
of conversation but to me i didn't see
it as a a a money play like i wouldn't
pay 44 billion for for for twitter that
seems like over valuation i think he may
be walked into a trap
yeah because they're like oh by the way
the reason we do all this is because we
have a national security letter and the
government's got their gun to our back
and now you bought it it's on you it's
on you yeah and he's like oh crap yeah i
think this is this is a very powerful
tool twitter is a very powerful tool i
don't know how you monetize it but he
was talking about some a rumor
i don't know if you guys saw this he
wanted to turn it into like the wechat
of america where he wanted all the
payment systems and everything oh right
right you guys agree with that oh i
don't know about you what's wechat
firstly well in china like wechat right
i do have wechat i mostly made it as a
joke but i took it off my phone when i
saw that um
my phone was browsing fishing sites for
like 10 hours what
what
yeah you got hacked or something i mean
i don't know that if that means i was
hacked it stopped after i deleted it
[Laughter]
so what are you supposed to conclude
from that
um what is wechat
it's one of the big chinese social media
platforms beyond uh weibo right that's
the other one that's like the equivalent
of facebook um
and this one is sort of like whatsapp
um you have to get
endorsed or recommended by another user
who already has an account
um
so i had to like
reach out to somebody that i knew who
knew someone who had it
to
give me like a voucher to get on the
platform it's like very exclusive and
they don't want westerners on it
they're owned by 10 cent
uh i imagine it's just basically the ccp
such as a chinese company that's yeah
and they they really only want chinese
citizens on it
okay ideally but like like you're you're
you're i made it as a joke to be like
you can find me on wechat like as a joke
that's hilarious by the way um
that's hilarious
but but they but everything's on there
right like you pay i guess your mortgage
through this thing really
yeah yeah every like all your payments
atm i don't know don't get me the line
but if you all i saw as like the most
basic functions like posting a picture
posting something that looks like a
tweet yeah but we have a chinese citizen
like everything yeah you can't survive
in china without wechat or something so
you're saying kind of like facebook in a
sense yeah there you go but i guess i
guess facebook you use facebook to pay
your mortgage right
there so you're talking about turning
into a payment system like a payment
services uh platform that's that's true
because the metaverse is blending uh
social media and payment services as
well as like all sorts of voting
services they're trying to blend like
yeah all these things together so you're
it's basically your life in the digital
space centralization yeah i want to
swipe right on that guy and send him 10
cents and that guy and send him five
dollars or whatever
yeah jack dorsey was trying to get he's
been integrating payment systems with
twitter while he was there yes well he
has what is it what does he do cash app
cash apps and square and then they want
bitcoin tips i think too or some was in
bitcoin yeah all right yeah you get
tipped in bitcoin yeah well look we'll
see we'll see what happens to the elon
stuff but it's friday night and i think
it's time we we get to the more fun
story here
here we go ladies and gentlemen from
newsweek
joe biden mocked for a parent
teleprompter flub repeat the line yo
this is amazing you ready for this one
let's play it is noteworthy that the
percentage of women who registered to
vote and cast a ballot is consistently
higher than the percentage of the men
who do so end of quote repeat the line
women are not without
[Laughter]
repeat the line the men who do so end of
quote repeat the line end of quote
repeat the line here's the funny thing
you ready for this
newsweek reports he's mocked for an
apparent teleprompter flub
end of quote is not the first time he
has read that okay and guess who fact
checked it as false also newsweek
amazing fact check did joe biden
accidentally read teleprompter
instruction during speech this is from
november 2021 november 24th
false the phrase end of quote was not a
teleprompter instruction accidentally
read by biden it was part of the speech
used to bookend the walmart ceo's remark
which biden began citing seconds earlier
with the phrase to quote the walmart ceo
how many people have you ever met hugo
and i was talking to this activist who
said quote i enjoy going uh to the mall
to shop end of quote sometimes i'll say
close quote but that's the course or end
quote
end quote but typically people just say
quote that's usually for like an audio
book yeah something really formal yeah
yeah i think the reality is
they put that in there as instructions
right and repeat the line because
they're supposed to pull it back and
then biden just ron burgundy is it at
the very least it's not the phrase end
of quote that's in contention it's the
phrase repeat the line and then and then
i didn't do it and right and he didn't
do it and a white a white house staffer
said he actually said let me repeat the
line oh he didn't say no he i they
actually tweeted that's crazy that's
what they said they're gaslighting and
you know why they do that
because what's going to happen now is
the media will say
conservatives accuse joe biden of x
white house says why and people who
don't pay attention to pay attention to
the news will see that story and not the
fact that joe biden read the prompter
like ron burgundy and that they're
trying not to laugh in the background
that was the best part how does kamala
not laugh around her face changes
let me let me let her face changes look
at this it's more contempt on her feet
yeah she's like let me pull this one up
let's make it i want to see comments
like cringy look at the guy on the right
he's trying not to laugh
look at him he's like i hope he doesn't
mess this up i think i think kamala is
just like you think she'll write a book
like my time as the vp yeah
i want to mention who do you know who
this guy on the right is that looks like
rob emmanuel maybe no that's not the
name he does kind of look like him i
mean he's blind
the guy on the right is like holding
back laughing kamala harris i can
imagine what's going on in their heads
the guy on the right in his head he's
like don't laugh don't laugh don't laugh
kamala harris in her mind it's
cause look at her face she's just like
when you hear her talk she just says
words
one of the replies to this was like
she says he repeated the line because
the line was there and he wanted to say
it again because he needed to repeat the
line
like that's how she talks
this is why they gave him instructions
that said you do this you do this
because if you don't oh right
that's that's that's great yeah so
simon says game remember that card you
is so big on the card right so he
doesn't actually read it that explains
it so he had a card and it said you
stand up you talk to the press you ask
because when you don't put that there he
actually just does exactly verbatim
yo this guy is not all with it do you
think he's on drugs yeah oh yeah of
course
but uppers uppers yeah yeah this dude's
probably on so much meth i just saw a
video of him from like four years ago
i'm not i'm not saying like he's smoking
crystal i'm saying yeah adderall
adderall and other uppers other math
derivatives and things like that
those around means yeah adderall is not
meth it's different amphetamines but
right some kind of okay i should say
meth sometimes amphetamine i'll say but
it's funnier to say meth i mean
honestly it's funnier to think that he's
just smoking like the christmas he's got
the blue stuff from walter white they
was giving him a good
they would have him sleep for 20 hours
and wake up right before
then they would give him an iv drip of
some real legit upper he's just on
another planet yeah dude his eyes were
like his pupils were dilated he's like i
can see everything were his eyes
bleeding a few yeah
like terrifying and then pair that with
his like cheshire cat's smile
i remember when his eye popped on stage
yeah yeah like a blood vessel or
something crazy was that you think i was
drug induced because i've never seen it
happen before since well stress maybe
just it can be a lot of things
but drugs can induce stress as well you
know what i think it really was like
because it popped before he went on
stage right
no i think it popped on stage you sure i
think so cause i was gonna say he's
probably making a boom boom and he's old
man so he was like
for real let it happen yeah that's
terrible you guys watch the new one
i'm sorry didn't he poo his pants in
front of the pope or something that's
awesome
is that confirmed fact check i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna look i'm gonna
google search
it was weird that they they wouldn't
okay here we go you guys we got it
snopes has got the truth okay did biden
poop his pants in rome
another president another pants pooping
rumor
false
hold on there a minute
there was a rumor that trump did the
same what the heck there was a rumor
that trump hired
lady women of the night to relieve
themselves on a bed that's a little i
mean yeah but snopes is funny like when
they do the fact check this like yes
there were traces of feces in his
underwear
but it wasn't a full poop
so therefore false right that's what
they do
they say an actual rumor is not a fact
oh okay oh that explains it so look at
this he says there's no evidence his
claim the claim wasn't derived from
photos or biden
the story was that
joe biden was apparently
having some meeting and then
mysteriously went absent for a short
amount of time and then came back
wearing some other clothes or something
and everyone's like he pooped his pants
and i'm i'm like i agree i don't know if
he actually did
like remember the pissy kid used to come
to school with extra pair of pants
like in like kindergarten
bro had to clean himself up
i've been watching the um the secret
what is her job the woman the press
sector yeah the press secretary she
speaks for him this new girl and she
says um a lot i want to get ahead of her
what is her name
i don't know what the new black lady
yeah what's her name i only remember
redhead yeah that was jen sackey yeah
she was in suffering
she just keeps this woman kareem is her
name yeah oh man i want to point out
that she says um way too much does she
yeah she says things that just aren't
true way too much and she also says i
don't know way too much oh what about
hunter bind's laptop i have no idea you
gotta talk to hunter biden's gotta talk
to the white house about that it's owned
but jen sackey would say we're gonna
circle back to that right she was way
better they don't circle back yeah well
saki had more experience
you know when you're like a
well-seasoned communists like lying's
just comes with the territory exactly
well it's it's like
when you look into their eyes you don't
see a soul
and it's just they're programmed they
can say whatever they need to with a
straight face
yeah i mean i mean
just the blatant line
that the left
the left conducts is just egregious oh
remember remember remember when uh jack
basoba got punched yes and then the cops
walked up having witnessed it and that
fat auntie for one goes nothing happened
yeah it's just like those eyes dude
those evil lying eyes
there's not a trace that they're
doubting what they're saying like they
really are believing no no they know
they're lying she she was like smirking
like nothing happened i didn't see
anything and the cops were like yeah we
witnessed it we're listening like lying
is good if you're lying against an evil
entity like the nazis where where are
you hiding the jews and you're like i
don't have any jews in this house but
you are hiding people that you're saving
that you're you're a liar but you're
doing it so these people probably are
just so what they think well that's what
saul lelinski says right the end
justified it means some people believe
all lying is unethical
yeah regardless of consequences or
circumstances i don't know
maybe jordan peterson like what if what
if you know like i'd like what is that
what if shots fine like what if your kid
is like
you know mom am i attractive what's the
mom gonna say yo you're ugly
i did that once to my kid man oh how was
it it was terrible oh my gosh
he came to me he said he drew like this
this picture
and he's a young boy and he was like
seven or eight at the time he said dad
what do you think this picture and i
asked him i said do you want to know the
truth of what i think and he looked me
and i said yeah i want to know the truth
i said bro that [ __ ] is ugly
and he started breaking down crying i'm
like i'm such an idiot i am so stupid
like this is what i'm saying i was
supposed to lie duh did you like give
him specific criticisms like that nose
is too big no after you started crying i
was like man i'm just playing bro that
[ __ ] is good
no but you you don't like if it's if
it's a little kid and they're trying you
know you don't got to say that's
terrible you just feel like
you're doing really well you didn't want
to improve but the way he said it was
like he wanted constructive feedback
right like i was trash
i was in i was hanging out with three
grown adults and we were having a
conversation about the grown folk stuff
and i said can i provide some criticism
and he says we don't use the word
criticism here it's called constructive
feedback so you know you're definitely
dealing with some democrat
[Laughter]
they have to make it as verbose as
possible yeah as if it like softens the
offense so what do you think is the best
thing with a kid that wants the truth
like are you like well i don't like it
but let me tell you why
this line's a little crooked you could
do this a little straighter you have a
lot of goo and then give him a
compliment sandwich like i don't know
kids understand the complexities of that
yeah no you just say you know what
you're on your way to great art you're
gonna be awesome this is a great start
you just gotta go with that you know
we're still honest but it's not saying
right you know
or you can mix it up a little bit and be
like you're on your way to being really
really great you keep working at this
you're going to be fantastic
the honest truth is you're no rembrandt
right not yet yeah so so but you got to
keep that's pretty hard that is pretty
harsh but you're no rembrandt
no i'd say it's more of a monet not
monet
and then if your kid actually knows
anything about art they're like
cringe how dare you you're more of a
picasso you know because you're more of
a jackson really ugly just like you did
the next picasso that's what you can do
you can you can be like he's a famous
artist you know jackson pollock right so
when your son writes draws trash you can
just be like well you know
some people like it so the the press
secretary is treating us like a little
kid that she doesn't want to make start
crying by being like the economy is in
shambles and we're like oh
yeah
it's great
economy is fantastic yeah you're doing
great you're going to be fine i don't
know that's what they were lying about
the whole uh
ukraine i'm gonna i'm not allowed to say
that here on youtube but
the whole gas right like oh gas prices
are low because putin and it's just like
what like
right right gas prices are high because
of putin right
they're low in russia but right
but they lied about that right like and
and then they they used britney griner
as a political pawn and said she's
locked up because putin is like no she's
locked up because she broke a law
just just stop and think about how
amazing this is gas prices are
skyrocketing
people are complaining about gas prices
going up yeah then one day putin invades
ukraine and biden goes oh those gas
prices it's putin and all these
democrats go oh
that explains it and we're like dude
that just happened the price of gas was
all ready already right and they're like
nah
it's like okay man yeah everybody's
looking for the villain who's the
villain who's the villain something bad
who's this villain there's gotta be a
villain because of this this is what i
imagine that that fat auntie for a woman
when jack was punched and she looks at
him she's like i didn't see anything and
you it's like she got that smart on her
face remember when that struck guy
whatever his name is
peter strzok yes and he's testifying as
a thing with his eyes
and christine blasey four does it too
these people like envision themselves as
like gi joe villains that's what it
looks like like
it's like
you're acting like you're evil dude do
they believe they're
on the side of good though i don't know
maybe they think they're villains the
guy that said that we need to protect
the liberal world order it was pretty
much like i think he thinks he's on the
side of good but that the side of good
is the liberal world is like global
military american dominance so that
means his boss has completely got him
conditioned and brainwashed i just yeah
he's
like literally
creme de la creme of the sheep but i'm
wondering these days like do you know
the liberal warlord are you familiar for
the century do you know much about no
it's like the in 1946 they built it
after world war ii they're like we can
never have another world war we need to
set up military bases around the world
we're going to use the american military
as the forefront we're going to use the
american economy and it's like a global
the um industrial military industrial
complex basically so now they called it
the new world order george bush senior
was like we're going to set up a new
world order and they're talking about
improving this liberal order this
liberal world order and it's basically
there's this or there's like the chinese
world order which is bricks uh brazil
russia china india south africa
um so it's like we're gonna have one
world order another i mean we might be
able to to resist and have like a
decentralized union which is ideal in my
opinion but
right now we have these world competing
world orders and it's like do we support
the the liberal one or do we just wrote
a book i wrote a book on a world order
okay uh it's called the patriot report
unmasking the conspiracy of money and
war and there was this funny part in my
book about the bretton woods agreement
and and how they were able to convince
the united states to be um the reserve
currency for
these nations
and that was pretty
uh eye-opening studying the brandwoods
agreement in keynes and how they put
this together and then how
that led into uh
i would call hyperinflation of the
dollar i think that's 1971 that happens
when it
brentwood's agreement basically
dissolves but that that when i looked at
the brentwood's agreement like i think
that was 1944 brentwood's agreement
somebody got to look that up um don't
get me the line but it lines up with
what you said like that whole world
order around that same time period so
now when you say it i'm like maybe
there's some connectedness there it's
falling apart 1944 yeah that's 44. yeah
there you go when when epstein
is mainstream like the whole episode
story when maxwell's being publicly
sentenced they won't reveal the client
list
when the georgia guidestones are blown
up
when they're shooting at farmers
meanwhile there's a food shortage coming
you know the narrative is collapsing i
understand the hatred of the patriarchy
that like oh we've got these old roman
guys basically trying to own everyone
through religion and through you know
whatever god is a man all this nonsense
but like
it doesn't mean that just destroying it
is the way to go because there's much
worse things out there as well we got to
keep that in mind yeah chinese communism
is very dangerous the ccp is very
dangerous the citizens are like on
lockdown 24 they're like well let's
let's let's talk a little bit about this
uh this is the story from npr shinzo abe
killed at 67 leaves a storied legacy as
japan's longest serving premiere so for
those that didn't see the story i mean
this may
this it's been a crazy week right i know
the large hadron collider just fired up
but man already yeah crazy as soon as
that thing opened and i mean it's
honestly it's been a crazy past month or
so but so shinzo abe in japan he's the
longest serving pro prime minister he's
very popular and he was shot in the back
cowardly cowardly assassination the dude
had a homemade shotgun
so
you know people talk about how he
opposed china he was conservative he
opposed communism and so many are
wondering what was the motivation for
taking him out could it be that japan
was leading
leading the cause against china in the
in southeast asia
you look at what joe biden's doing with
his son
joe biden
was was taken oil out of the strategic
reserve and about a million barrels were
given to china through a company called
um uh what is it do you remember what
it's called
no i don't no no no unit unesco unesco
no no no no no
sonic or whatever i can't remember the
name okay no i can't sorry we could we
could pull it up but um
you have to wonder you know his sons
involved in these companies had
apparently invested some something to
private equity
it really does look like
they're trying to give or hoard wealth
and bring it to china
you look at what happens to shinzo abe i
think
they're not going to win
when when these actions are overt and in
the public and it's no longer a
conspiracy theory it looks like the
liberal world order the their global
agenda is failing
they are desperately trying to stop the
holes they're bursting in the hole but
they can't do it do you think that the
people like the the global banking
establishment for instance like the bank
for international settlements in
switzerland is it intentionally
moving the wealth and power away from
the liberal world order world order i
gotta get this right liberal world order
into brics the chinese world order
and it's intentional and that's why
they're happy to see all this hatred of
the liberal world order um but they're
still using the american government as
pawns to try and act like we're
defending it um
well that's a good point i mean
this
unipac unipac was that was a chinese
company
and it was associated with um sign up
pack as the is the parent company of
which hunter biden uh is tied to
in 2015 a private equity firm he
co-founded bought a 1.7 billion dollar
stake in sinopec marketing so i just
think joe biden's gutting and selling
out the system and i think a lot of it
is they're trying i think they're trying
to transfer wealth to china who invested
you said that transfer wealth to china
biden's son invested in sign a pack
hunter biden is tied to sound effect how
a private equity firm he co-founded
which bought 1.7 billion dollar 1.7
billion dollar stake and sign up okay
the president's son is investing in
china in the communist chinese
oil companies this is freakish joe
his company is doing it and joe biden
took our oil and sent it their way oh
look we're not enemies at every turn i
get that but like at some point
like put the cards on the table
well when you sit
when you sit in the position of power
um
it gives you opportunity
to make uh a fortune for yourselves and
i think that you know especially when
you use these terms like liberal world
order these people don't have an
allegiance to
america or united states per se right
they have an allegiance to their club to
their families right we weren't invited
out to uh what's the club that they just
went out to out there in switzerland
davos davos we want to invite the davos
right so
i think it's that club and then when we
start saying like you know moving money
into china it could be a little bit of
hedging their bets right like you put a
little bit of money here i think they're
trying to invest in ukraine right and
they're just trying to hedge their bets
my thing is
especially when i've been studying uh
russian history which is quite
fascinating
um
they they
it seems like russia is the one place
they just can't penetrate too deeply
this world order and they've been poking
at it for a long time obviously going
back to uh the russian revolution etc
etc
been poking at this bear you know uh and
then you know the north was uh allied
you know abe lincoln basically owes
russia for helping him win that war the
civil war
so you know um
i don't know man i i look at russia as
being a key uh
component in all of this
so when i look at this table right the
pseudo table you know i guess there's
america sitting at the table and there's
some chinese man sitting the table and i
think the russian russian oligarchs were
kicked out the club i guess right
and they're just not allowed at the
table anymore but i think russia has
always been its own thing and i think
that's the one thing they're trying to
conquer but i think there's somebody
buddy with china oh absolutely because
china is so
the population
they've come so far in in just a short
amount of time this is a backwards
agrarian society at one point like
they're all farmers and then they
started producing shoes and then they
became a superpower and bootleg and
everything and they got a strong
military and
i think we we fear them i think there's
some legitimate fear there
i think everything we're seeing the
board is just the liberal world order
has fallen
yes they've lost control they lost
control
what is this liberal world order it's a
collection of um international interests
political leaders and corporations that
are working together to prevent world
war three that's uh to the council
yeah well through is that their excuse
or is that what they're really trying to
henry kissinger talked a lot about
limited war and the idea was we would
set up proxy wars rather than say that
there's some russian aggression
communists oh you're saying rather than
bomb moscow we just have war with them
in vietnam yeah we could blow up all our
weapons and then you know raytheon can
make a crapload of money yes still and
we can we can keep the the power
moving keep the bombs building but
without having to destroy each other
oh that makes sense okay yeah yeah you
can you can pull up the council on
foreign relations and they break down
what is the liberal world order or the
liberal economic world order so when
george w bush or um
anyone else says a new world order
they're talking about something evolving
from the liberal world order something
else
the funny thing is there's a conspiracy
theory 10 years ago right and now it's
just public information yeah it's kind
of how binding's advisors going on tv
and saying it yeah that's why i think
it's falling apart they needed to rule
from the shadows call you crazy if you
criticize them they can't anymore
now it's just the
the truth i think the new world order
that they're trying to do is i don't
know if it's the metaverse if it's like
klaus schwab's world economic forums
that the governments cannot control
themselves they need corporations to
control them
they need the cooperation it is
and he's wearing his like
sith outfit have you seen that that
cloak he wears that's a new world order
that could be established but i don't
like the idea of people being like
digital slaves um getting their body
heat harvested and oh yeah
as long as you're in charge you know
like one of the five people controlling
big tech silicon valley everyone else
you're screwed yeah why are we talking
about it like the world order that takes
power next is the last one
i mean we've had many world orders right
many dynasties empires nope just one
which one is that just one just just i
don't know biden
just biden
just by just globo homo
biden has been the uh uh the the the in
charge of it all since uh forever
actually yeah since atlantis this is
actually satan
the biden family is you know what's
funny is like sun tzu when you are
strong appear weak when you're weak
appear strong like the gag is that joe
biden goes up on stage and then says
nonsense and reads the prompter and then
he's like bernie as soon as he gets
backstage he stiffens up straightens up
says all right get to work ladies you
know everybody and he's like clean fast
sharp with it
it's like he's the 80th generation of
bidens who've been controlling the world
of andy kaufman is alive and well ladies
and gentlemen
obama you know criticized them and then
behind the scenes like joe i'm so you
know i had to say that because
okay you get it whatever you need sir i
feel like it's the roman world order was
pretty predominant and then they made
the catholic church to kind of they're
like well if we can't govern them with
our with our emperor anymore we're to
govern their minds with our religion and
well
dear yeah i would agree with that um i
just want to add to that
i i think it's sort of reverse order i
think
people were first ruled by religion and
then
uh later on it was uh i guess
nationality yes when was that
when what like when nation states came
to be well you had the islamic world
right the islamic world was a huge
superpower and that's ancient as well i
mean they kind of in a way
well it depends on what you would define
as ancient i mean
50 years old
it's 50 years old yeah if you would say
50 years old then yeah like you know but
like the ottoman
ottoman empire doesn't fall until i
guess what is the late 1800s early 1900s
yeah after world war one yeah so the
ottoman empire is like hugely islamic
etc etc so they had a lot of power in
fact the
you know if you read this book by
chancellor william called destruction of
african civilization uh there's uh if
i'm not misquoting him but there's a
part in there that basically says islam
is the reason why african civilizations
fell
and it's pretty interesting what his
theory is on that i can explain if you
want but yeah you have an elevator
version elevator pitcher yeah yeah
basically what he says is um
uh the the the missionaries of the
caliphate
sit on your borders and they basically
peddle their religion but the the people
that are sitting on the borders your
nation are also doubling as spies and
learning about your culture and your
ways and so on so forth how things move
and then basically what happens is
um
you know african is pit against african
because you're now choosing it my
african or my islam first and many
people were choosing islam over being
african so now you have this divided
nation and
he has a lot of evidence to support it
in the book uh i think it's a pretty
interesting theory the caliph it's
interesting because it's not national
it's like this
its own entity i don't know much about
it i just know that the head of the
caliphate is not necessarily the head of
the country yeah and so so is that they
would say the nation well the nation of
islam was a specific thing right that
was like a an organization that was
created yeah yeah but then you also have
then you have the church that comes down
right so like when you go into african
nations you'll see like the uh the white
jesus on the wall like i i i bury my
grandma i think it was last year in
jamaica and it was just hilarious to see
a whole black congregation and then them
have like a picture of white jesus on
the wall and all i just see is like
colonization
but i think
nations first ruled with religion and i
think you know after that economy
evolved and their the new religion is
something else now that's crazy though
because a lot of cultures have their own
ethnic
image of jesus like they're yeah we talk
about a lot there's japanese jesus
really yeah yeah yeah honest dope yeah
and uh um we've we've had sheamus on
talking about it too where he's just
like yeah of course every culture views
him as like you know as them or whatever
and there's like no issue there or
whatever and interestingly uh
apparitions of the virgin mary
are
often
different based on the culture
so
our lady of guadalupe appeared
their ethnicity in their cultural garb
but much different from
our lady of lourdes for instance or
fatima okay
um that's why i'm like i don't i don't
see it you know we see these memes all
the time from the left and they're like
here's what jesus really looked like and
it's like a sephardic that's not the
point obviously there's no description
of what jesus looks like in the bible
because that wasn't
the point of him being thought it was
daniel 7 verse 9 or daniel 9 7. i could
be wrong yeah i said he was six foot
five with bulging muscles and blonde
hair just he looked like jason mamoa
yeah from the from the from wait so
there's literally you say there is a
description of him but you were
mentioned
not to my knowledge is it i mean i could
see that that would be intentional if he
had like dark skin and they're like we
need to empower the roman patriarchy and
we need to disempower the jews let's
make people i think this guy's a white
guy i disagree i think if they wanted to
control you if the idea was about
control you would need to convince the
people he's of you
so yes the idea would be to make a
picture of a japanese jesus to make a
picture of an arabic jesus or a white
jesus so that those people would be like
oh yeah they're like me
so they gave no description or i want to
hear what you were saying what was it
called the the section where you thought
there was a description of jesus oh yeah
i said daniel 7 verse 9 of daniel nine
verse seven i'm no biblical god i could
be completely off but
uh that that just popped in my mind for
something i wanna i wanna i wanna jump
to this story real quick too we carry
this on just uh talking about
what happened in shinzo abe gun control
we're also talking about religion and
things like that which made me think of
you know a handmaid's tale and i have
this tweet i'm going to read it because
i don't care if i get in trouble on you
know youtube or whatever so i tweeted um
the good news is that once guns are
banned the handmaidens will have no way
to fight back against fascists and will
be forced to carry babies for fat
insults wow
so i just you know i thought of this
because i'm on facebook and i'm just
like
scrolling through it and then i see
i see an individual who posted two memes
the first meme was a handmaiden and it
was like the theocratic fascists are
forcing women to carry babies or
whatever and the next one was like we
should ban all guns i'm sick of this
just ban all of them and i'm like who do
you think will then have the guns yeah
like you think you're being ruled like
you're you're if you're in the
handmaid's tale and then you want the
theocratic fascists to have all the guns
and i was like maybe this will be like a
way for you to understand why that's a
bad thing
yeah
what was the name of the country uh
in hand mainstale i've never seen it
i read it or read it or anything i don't
know you don't know
nobody knows it's so stupid let me uh
hop out the window and just uh take a
guess here
italy
no no no it was like it was in north
america but they changed the name of the
country and it was like
women were forced to oh this is a
fictional place yeah yeah yeah
lightly fictionalized oh okay because it
looks very catholic
the garb
well that was the idea it's very puritan
not catholic yeah like a religion took
over
and now all these people are like we're
living in the handmaid's tale quick give
the government your guns the republic of
gilead gilead
yeah that's right because these people
have only read uh two books harry potter
and the handmaid's tale yep but as james
points out often they probably didn't
even read the books they watched the
adaptation
and this is it's a strongly patriarchal
white supremacist totalitarian this is
at least from wikipedia it could be
anything
theonamic
theocratic say what's a theonomics i
guess like the economy is based on
religion or something
like the god god king is on the coin and
stuff
[Music]
maybe
maybe they're getting at something you
know what's like really handmaid's tale
is
the fact that like pubescent girls are
put on the pill at like age 12
or like surrogacy is so common
i got it theonomy is hypothetical form
of government ruled by christian divine
law in which non-christians are excluded
from citizenship i thought that was
theocracy that sounds healthy actually
yeah well in a theocracy you can i think
you can be a non you cannot practice the
religion and still be assassinated but
in a theology you have to apparently
yeah or excluded hypothetical though so
maybe it's never
no one's ever existed before i like how
there's always one book they're like
it's 1984 and then a law changes no it's
the handmaid's tale harry potter because
it's 1984 again what was biden's
executive order something about
reproductive rights did you guys see
yeah oh yeah i saw something about that
what did he say again he said end of
line end of quote repeat the line that's
what he said that was the whole thing
that was the whole executive order uh
it's it's it's extremely limited let me
see if we can pull out because we didn't
have it pulled up uh there's not a whole
lot that he can do
but uh we do have the story here if it
loads we're getting we're being we had
some slow interviews timcast.com has
given us the business i debated a
congressional candidate a democrat
congressional candidate on the topic on
that topic roe v wade and
the decision and she actually
capitulated at the end really yeah like
what was what was your what was your
stance like what were you saying i just
said let's can we go by like the actual
scotus decision in the verbiage in the
held section right i think it's dobbs
versus jackson or whatever and i was
like can we just read what it says and
and judge that decision and say is this
decision fair yeah and she had to
capitulate it was after yeah i mean like
after you you know tell me your his hour
history or whatever of all the bad
things white people have done to black
people right but here's the funny thing
about the debate she said um
she would mandate
did you have yeah she said she wouldn't
mandate her fascists bro but she came on
the podcast saying that she was all for
body autonomy
with the whole roe v wade situation and
i'm just like how do you even so i said
to her i said they're not you just sat
here and told me every reason why we
can't trust white folk and then all of a
sudden when it comes to this all of a
sudden it's like we gotta listen to them
and i'm just like it's not about women's
healthcare it's about control
it's a it's they
you got really it is it is about control
because if you look at if we if if roe v
wade was never overturned that means
that scotus can weigh in on birth rights
let me eliminate or keep a b i i just
got to say it yo um
leftist you're in a cult and i'll tell
you why
abortion is defined by the cdc as the
the uh terminating a pregnancy in a way
that that does not result in a live
birth
that would mean that ectopic pregnancies
these are not abortions planned
parenthood outright says the uh i forgot
the name do you know the name of the
operation for uh
ectopic pregnancy is that's an l i think
it's not an abortion it's a surgical
procedure they have to do yeah uh there
was a there's a bunch of stories they're
talking about where it's like
uh one woman was like i had a dead baby
you know in my womb and they wouldn't
take it out it's like that's not an
abortion
that's a miscarriage and there's a name
stopping me sorry
planned parenthood even even talks about
this abortion is when you end the
pregnancy and and there's no live birth
so the baby is
so that's the abusive language well the
problem is these people don't understand
that so they're like i see these memes
and they go it's not about pro-life it's
about controlling women and it's like
the supreme court did not ban abortion
yeah you're talking about texas yeah
take it up with texas right yeah but but
when the supreme court goes we do not
have the authority over the states and
they cry about it they're fascists
they're the they're the authoritarians
who want to control you and have no
logic behind them around the problem is
the supreme court's acknowledging they
don't have the the right to decide for
people right but why would they give
that power to the governors like a
governor can decide for its entire state
that's because that's how the gov
constitution works yeah 10th amendment
says right
the states make their own rules
basically what they're what the the the
held section says is
we are uh
taking the authority and overturning it
or it says returning it
so if you're saying returning authority
that means they held authority but if
they return it to the states not to and
the people yeah but not to the governor
solely like that
the legislature how many people are in a
state legislation they're all different
some have some have hundreds it depends
on how they draw up their every state
has their own constitution some some
states are common well our commonwealth
systems some states are not some have a
general i think nebraska i think it's a
general assembly
and then some have representatives and
senators it's it's all different yeah
but basically what scotus is saying is
the term abortion does not exist
anywhere in this document right because
the people that created this country
weren't heathens like you anyway
but this term isn't in here and so
because it's in
it doesn't exist in here we don't have
any jurisdiction over it what we do have
jurisdiction over however is the fourth
amendment so if you want to claim that
your privacy was violated by having this
operation done you can come back here
and say yo they violated my privacy you
want to get okay cool you can't do that
states and that's a plausible argument
but you can't say i got the right to an
abortion because there's nowhere in the
constitution the word abortion you can
just press control f on it and the word
just doesn't pop up and that's all the
skoda's document is saying and what i
think it's it's very deleterious for for
the left especially like i'm not going
to say celebrities because celebrities
don't know better
but for the people that know better to
manipulate women and make them believe
that this decision banned abortion i
thought was really evil like there's
women out here that are going to have
real emotional reactions to this right
women are going to be crying
what if you break down crying in the
middle you know driving home you crash
like you're putting people's lives at
risk instead of saying hey can we teach
you how to read a scotus document a
scotus decision and then you can
interpret this however you see first you
see you see what happens with brett
kavanaugh at uh was it morton's
steakhouse
they show up he has to exit out the back
and then people started calling in fake
reservations to just jam up and hurt the
business see
you know these are crazy days indeed but
they are fascists like you said right
and people throw that work word around a
lot
yes so so
the reality is they're they're
they're more communist
and i don't mean that in the sense of
ideological communism i mean in the
sense of the like literal communism
fascists tend to be ultra traditionalist
authoritarian yeah that was a general
idea what we saw in europe and then you
had the communists both of them had a
salute both of them would raise their
right arm
the nazis would do the open hand roman
salute yeah and the communists would do
the closed fist red salute
today you can walk down the street and
do the communist salute the red salute
and nobody bats an eye right don't go
around doing the nazis so that people
will beat you up right so uh with with
europe you had people who want to erase
culture like in china for instance the
cultural revolution they wanted to purge
the old the fascists wanted to return to
tradition
these people
want to purge tradition
they want to purge religion they want to
purge tradition they want to create a
new system they are amoral
authoritarians so it is more in the
communist vein yeah oh it's definitely
communist
um
but communism and so so i think
communism is the is the mechanism with
which
fascism is is empowered because i define
fascism as being the control of the
economy right and and communism is like
the process of centralizing everything
you know even when you look at the 10 uh
planks of marxism i always talk about
this the word centralization pops up in
there twice right centralization of
credit within the hands of state and
centralization of communication right
and and we're starting to see in the
united states there is fcc obviously
exists but there is a centralization of
communication oppressed because it's all
the same people right so you see that
you know popping up the united states
but i see communism is i see the united
states as being a communist utopia
already like if if marx was alive today
he'd be like damn y'all are good
he'd really love it
because people don't know that they're
living in the communistic people think
they're living in a capitalistic
it's like no the capitalism is
supporting the communism and it's and
and and and if that right you look at
what china's doing
i love the political compass that
someone took it and then folded the left
and the right together and put china
because they're communists but they use
market forces and systems yes as a means
of control yes can you dive into your
explanation of the us being communist um
like at what level are you i have a
working theory i could give you
so um
united states was um 13 colonies in the
very beginning and then it was
somebody's idea to federate right
um and then well technically
it was their other british
quebec for instance was a british colony
and they said no we're not going to get
involved so it could have been 14. yeah
yeah
so um really decided to federate and
centralize power right
all right so let's put that aside then
you get the um
uh
the czar in russia is toppled and then
you get the uh
the democratic republic
right and what do they call that the
duma and then uh after that uh you get
the uh
uh colored revolution in germany and
then that becomes the vaimar republic
and that's also a democratic republic
and the um
and the king there
um
uh uh uh uh false right so i'm looking
at these commonalities and i'm like all
right so you have
uh some sort of feudalist state at that
point and then communism comes in which
is basically just a revolution to to to
centralize power and they bring this
thing to a democratic republic and i'm
looking at united states i'm like united
states is technically a democratic
republican and we have a centralization
and then there's the whole thing about
the templates of communism all being
executed united states um but the main
thing for me was
uh the lenin quote 90 of communism was
creating a central bank and i like i
said i wrote a book on these central
banks of america and i'm just looking at
all this stuff and i'm like this is very
communistic
so i just i don't view you know for
example when we look at something like
minimum wage
like minimum wage is a a socialist
machination right
um
soviets pushed for for something like
that and it's also got like uh racist
roots as well
but um when you see stuff like that in
america like minimum wage is like the
first
red flag that we live in a communist
nation is so minimum wage is just a
horrible heart no fault divorce was
communist apparently too um
really yeah 1917. was that was that you
who brought that up yeah yeah it's crazy
it was shocking that was the first
introduction of it explain that well
that the idea that uh in any type of
marriage you could just get divorced for
no reason was unheard of until the
communists lenin and his friends in 1917
overthrew the tsar nicholas and uh one
of the destroyers like yeah if you want
to leave yeah destroy you know whatever
reason i don't know and i'm tertiary
surface they will understand they want
the state to be your family they want
you to be dependent upon the state this
is iron the communist russians were very
much fascist yes that's that's fascism
is when the government controls business
essentially the collusion and now the
federal reserve is very much fascist
it's the collusion now i'm wondering
does that mean that it's communist not
necessarily you can have fascism without
communism i think or
it's just the idea of fascism because
you can say that the government doesn't
own alphabet doesn't own google but man
they can make them do what they want
twitter they can make twitter
shut their mouth the execs like do stuff
that's that's they can make it
disturbing
you can get served the national security
letter people don't understand this man
these big media companies
the you you think that elon musk can get
in twitter and say get into twitter and
save the day you think that uh i'll say
this even of tim cast and the daily wire
if what what what would we do what would
what would you do if
tomorrow the nsa the fbi whoever else
comes the national security letter and
says for these reasons you have to turn
over your data and you can't do these
things
dare dare us go against us
there have been a few companies that
have chosen to shut down there was one
famous email uh encrypted email provider
that said we won't do it we're shutting
down our company and refusing to to hand
over the data and then told everybody we
were serving the national security
letter but that
they could they could you know google
you for that stuff absolutely so most
people you want you know why you don't
hear about that all that often because
they're not going to go up against the
us government well they're not allowed
to get gag orders too if you tell people
that you got the order that's also a
violation of the that's the point if if
if we got i'll tell you this i would
shut this company down in two seconds if
they came and tried to mandate we did
anything but this stuff happens they'll
come in and say for national security
reasons that story is dead and i'd be
like first hey i'm afraid you're ain't
you and they'd be like then you're done
and i'll be like what you got to
understand
i'll stop there
and completely change the subject and
say
there was a journalist who
was about to break a big story on a
general
and then he complained that somebody was
tampering with his car
and then he got in his car
and then died because the car was
speeding down wilshire boulevard like 90
or something and then rammed into a tree
and blew up
so uh you have to wonder about stories
like that or remember that guy who um
was investigating the cia in crack and
then he shot himself twice in the head
in a suicide
look
you hear these stories and the coroners
or the the the autopsy report comes out
and it's like yes he was hung and then
shot himself in the chest and the face
in a suicide
and you're like how could that make
sense it's not supposed to it's supposed
to be telling you
this is what happens
when you go against us yeah yeah i like
what you were saying bro about like um
that
marx would be
satisfied with what we've got going on
because we think we're in a capitalist
society but actually you think you own
your data if you're like a programmer
but if the government if the ci comes
and says you give us that you have
you're bound i mean i gotta say under
duress before you know i don't agree
i'll meet you halfway marx would would
he would be sitting down with some white
liberal woman and going like
wow you've done very good very good and
then he turns the tv on and he sees all
the woke stuff and he's like oh because
he's racist
he's like yeah he's super racist so he
says like no no no what are you doing
yeah yeah he'd actually freak out i
think there's going to be some culture
shock but like after they explain to him
like how well this is working about
bringing he's going to go okay this is
kind of genius you've used the n-words
to bring about oh wow i didn't even
think of that and you made the chinese
look like the bad guy and you made the
chinese he was like he was like a racist
rich kid wasn't he yeah oh well i mean
his homie was supporting them angles
angles was was uh supporting them oh you
used super rich angles yeah this is a
good story he had a couple of businesses
yeah this is the friedrich engels this
is the problem i think who was
mentioning this before the show i think
maybe it was euian or something that uh
someone had ryan longheaded joke about
how all these people you know that
they're spoiled because they're like why
would you want to live in america no i
wasn't who was talking about that i
don't know
i think it was a ryan ryan long made the
joke
that you've got these uh
these millennials you know you know
they're like spoiled first worlders as
they're like america's terrible
meanwhile like people from guatemala are
crawling through deserts and dying in
the middle of like 90-mile vast
wastelands desperate to come here i
think is it sri lanka where they're they
have gasoline rationing now only for
emergency vehicles people are lined up
like what do they you know
i love america man i think america's
beautiful piece often people like oh i
want to leave the country on vacation
i'm like why i like america i like no
i'm down i'm like hey i got an idea like
i've offered to send leftists to israel
really like i will buy you a plane
ticket we'll go out get your hotel room
have you talked to people and then
they're like but israel and they go on
and talk about evils and all that stuff
and then it's like i'm not saying don't
talk to the palestinians i get it but
bro
imagine what it must be like to be
living in a house not understanding the
political what's going on with
government not being involved in
government and the rocket blows up over
your house you want to talk about hard
living you want to complain about life
in america wait till the rocket lands
that slams into your neighbor's building
kills your neighbor's kid and then be
like
oh life is hard to america
they can so so i it's this is the
problem with most of these activists
i'm not saying i'm not i'm not trying to
take sides in israel palestine or
anything like that i'm just saying you
got to recognize for people in palestine
when the bomb comes down life is not
easy for people in israel when a rocket
slams in their building life is not easy
at the very least you can say it's way
better in america in terms of safety
security and comfort
and these people born in this country
with their hipster mustaches and their
and their man buns are complaining about
how bad it is here
i would like to buy that person a ticket
and bring them to complexo del alamao in
in brazil and let you go and see what
it's like you ever see the open air
sewers in brazil
so in the favelas because favelas
shantytowns basically and they just
build where they build there is a i did
an interview with a gang leader and
we're standing on this little bridge
and the bridge was above an open air
sewer where you would see pvc pipes
sticking out from where the houses are
and then just turns
and they just splatter and then when it
rains it just washes it down into the
ocean and that's what you live next to
yeah and that's when you walk out your
front door that's what you're looking
you're not looking at a street you're
looking at an open-air sewer system and
i'm like i'd love to bring you there and
talk to you about poverty about the
people who don't have running water so
what they have is they have vats on
their roof when it rains it fills up and
that's what you get to flush the toilet
so if it doesn't rain i went to a favela
i was went to a house and i was
interviewing a family and their toilet
was just stacked up with with with crap
and i was like can i use your bathroom
like it's right here and then i'm like
it's like above the toilet like how do i
use it and they're like just pile it on
they're like we'll flush it when we can
flush it we don't have any water right
having those water collectors is luxury
i was in seriously in peru in the
iquitos in the bay lin district and they
were just pooping in the river and then
where all the trash was just plastic
everything just you could barely even
see water when you look into the into
the riverway and then they would drink
that water too they didn't we're never
educated oh you know what's funny that's
the vaccine i i i talk about how uh
chickens are smart enough not to drink
water they've crapped in but not smart
enough not to crap in their water and
then i realized like humans aren't even
that smart they'll crap in the water and
then drink it yeah uneducated it was
ignorance but the chickens don't do it
like so so we put the water thing out
and the chickens will stand over it and
they just look at you and they're like
all dumb and they just go like they
squat and then just crap right in the
water and then you'll watch and walk up
and look at it and like look around and
then walk away because they know like i
can't drink that but they don't realize
they did it right and so we make fun of
them for it and then i was watching some
video about how people were in the river
just crapping and then other people were
scooping water out for their drinking
water and i'm like i guess chickens are
doing a little better than us did you
ever live in front of them around the
world
i've traveled um my family's from
jamaica
so
i've seen um
real poverty uh i've been to africa
tanzania to be exact and tanzania was
really dope i actually want to bring my
modern life out there
um
but uh
jamaica was different like even just
going to my grandma's house in jamaica
was really rough uh they didn't have
water pressure
so like you turn it on and just like you
know drips and you got to just shower
with drips so the water pressure you
know depending on what time of day who's
doing what
you know you had some water pressure so
when we went to resort you kind of
appreciate just water pressure right um
the roadways are really bad etc etc but
beautiful island beautiful people
better food they the food i ate in
africa was amazing the food i ate in
jamaica is just way more fresh than what
we get here that's this is the crazy
thing isn't it that you you'd think
going to
a poor country you get worse food you
actually get better food it's for a very
simple reason it's simple food yes so
like i'm hanging out in i went to
thailand
and uh it's not like thailand's all that
but i was in bangkok and uh i was with
this dude and he was like you want real
thai food and i was like yeah and we go
to a neighborhood very poor and we walk
into this like it's like the corner of
the street they just have like they pull
up raf like the shutters and then
there's tables
and then she comes out with a piece of
steamed chicken and steamed rice and
that was it and he was like this is this
is thai food and i was like it's just
steamed chicken and rice i guess
anywhere and he's like that's what food
is yeah i went to brazil and when you go
to the poorer areas it's steak
you come to america and what do you get
some kind of styrofoam bun with some
weird ammonia processed burger
and it's like we're eating weird garbage
but you go to poor areas and they're
like oh it's a steak it's fresh too yeah
we just killed it like two minutes ago
yeah yeah because they don't have the
freezers they don't have the transport
so it's like you have the animal off the
farm you gotta cook kill it cook it eat
it yeah i always said if i was gonna be
homeless i would probably move to miami
because you can just eat fresh daily
right catch your little fish throw you a
little fire together you got good
weather coconuts everywhere coconuts
everything coco coconut doesn't mean
coconuts for the win
especially with the economy looking like
it's invest i'm not giving you a
financial advice but investment in
coconuts is not the worst thing you
could do
oil coconut water i watched a video
where a dude took a coconut and he cut
it
perfectly and then pried the ends off
and pulled the perfect white coconut
meat with the water all in it jiggling
and put it in a bowl it was like it was
a viral video
that sounds like the best thing ever
yeah when i lived in brooklyn years ago
there was this guy who was dressed in
like a safari outfit with a machete and
he had fresh sugar cane coconut and
melon and he would take the thing and
machete and he would chop the coconut
pour it in scoop the coconut meat then
he would press the sugar cane right in
front of you
all the sugar cane juice and then he
would throw melon and blend it up and i
was like that is breakfast you ever had
sugar cane juice before no sugar cane
juice
sugar cane juice i chewed on sugarcane
not quite not sugar you had two kings
yeah man bro amazing sugarcane juice
is
the best
juice on the planet
it's actually called sugar cane that's
the the veg
it's a fibrous plant yeah and then yes
they put it in this expel expeller press
yes and so it gets smashed through and
then all the juice just pours they just
soak it and then smash it that's good i
don't know what they do dog all i know
is
i had it twice i'm gonna say twice in
jamaica i had it regularly
but that was when i was a child right so
i didn't remember and then last time i
was an adult i went to africa i went to
tanzania and do so i got sugar cane
juice i said no you don't so yes i do
and yeah but you get a limited amount
because you know he's only bring a
certain amount of sugar cane with him i
mean i was drinking that stuff it's not
probably good for you because it's like
pure sugar yeah
but the rest of the time they're having
such wholesome food
that yeah it doesn't even matter right
fresh season it's fresh do you think
that um
i mean where have you been in africa
tanzania just tanzania okay yeah
do you think maybe they're happier than
americans i'ma tell you this
i hung out with the natives and i was
jealous okay
um
they they are
homeless i guess you can say
but they ate better than me right like i
sat down and i had a fresh
fish but i probably paid 20 bucks for it
they had the same fresh fish and they
didn't pay anything they went got it
they went and got it they got in their
little canoe their boat
and they went out they caught it they
cooked it
and i said
that's not fair i want to live like that
but they live off the land right so you
ever hear that old there's an old uh i
guess you'd call it parable or story
about
the rich guy who's vacationing you know
rich guy goes down to central america
and he's fishing and he sees this man
who gets in his little boat and goes out
and fishes and he's watching him the man
catches a couple fish loads him up and
leaves and he goes hey you might ask
what you're doing and he's like oh i'm
working for the day i'm going to go sell
the fish
and then the guy the rich guy says no
you're doing it all wrong
you could stay out here for another
couple hours catch twice as many fish
sell it save up buy a bigger boat and
the guy goes oh and then what do i do
and he goes he's like
i'm sorry i'm ruining the story but he
basically says like what are you doing
the guy the old the little guy says you
know i caught some fish i'm gonna bring
to the market i'm gonna sell it and for
the rest of the day i'm gonna hang out
with my family we're gonna play music
and we're gonna drink and have fun and
he's like no you're doing all wrong he
says stare twice as long
sell twice as many fish save up by a
bigger boat and he goes okay then what
do i do then with the bigger boat you
can catch even more fish sell those fish
then you get two boats now you got to
make it of a fleet and he says okay then
what now you got a big fleet
you sell way more fish you set up your
own processing plant you start selling
canned fish you market all over the
world and he goes okay and then what and
he goes the best part is once you're on
the top and you're the biggest you sell
the company you make millions of dollars
in profit
and that's where you need to be and he
goes okay but then what do i do is the
best part then you come down to central
america you go fishing for a few hours
in the day then you can go and hang out
with your family and play music have
some drinks and the joke was like that's
what the dude was doing already yeah
like that was my point when i saw it i'm
like yo um
i'm pretty sure people work
to have the life of the native
to be fair
you work because you need health care
and
we might we might envy that they're
they're gonna eat fresh meat yeah well
think about it these people are gonna
are gonna have fresh meat yeah even
people i watch this documentary about
people in siberia and it's like they're
eating like walrus and stuff and they're
super ripped and healthy
and you're like man look at they've got
family they have community they laugh
together they're happy
not like these sad people in the city
they're eating real food they work for
it every day and they're having the time
of their lives then they stub their toe
get an infection have you cut their foot
off or they have to seek aid to get
antibiotics somewhere for us we do a lot
of this because you get sick
you get treatment here's the thing
though
we're making ourselves sick from the
garbage we're producing and the
pollution so it's like find that happy
medium maybe that story is wrong maybe
you do want to work hard you do want to
save up some resources so you can take
care of yourself and your family while
you're off
living a simpler life and having fresh
food i don't know man them tribes got
their own witch doctor
that's hardcore i'm not i'm not sure
like
cutting a hole in my head and draining
blood will cure my my headache no no you
just they smoke salvia or something no
they eat the the tree bark with the
aspirin in it mm-hmm so this is the
crazy thing too like a lot of these uh
holistic remedies and stuff they used to
talk about and people are like oh that's
dumb just take aspirin it's like yo the
bark they're chewing on is the
derivative where the aspirin came
exactly so they know a lot of stuff and
look obviously there's a lot of herbs
that have an impact people people this
is really important because people think
they can drink like certain herbs and
ingest it and you need to realize
there's chemicals that do affect you
like drugs some of these weird you know
herbal remedies and like realistic
things absolutely but some people there
are people who think it's all fake
nonsense you could like put the herbs in
your food and eat it it's like that's
going to do something to you yes
my question for you brian is how
technological do you like to be as a
personal balance for yourself and your
future like how much tech do you want
involved like would you download your
brain into a computer i imagine you
would have said no if i'd asked you that
question
um if you could transition out of the
like how extreme involving tech like
obviously you have a social media
presence and you know your uh could you
get neuralink in your
definitely do no damn no really
oh no
no no no no no
i
i look at keeping up with technology as
a defensive mechanism okay
if you don't keep up with the
advancement of
weapons as a technology you were
conquered by the people who have more
advanced weapons right
um social media has become a weapon so
if you don't have your own social media
company
how do you fight back right if you don't
have your own vc network who's going to
invest in your technology company some
very
i believe that technology is um
is the real evolution of man right and i
think the more evolved technology gets
the less evolve humans become we be sort
of devolve away from our potential
um and but the technology gets better
and it makes our life easier right so
i'm with the technology but i'm also
like now i need to farm with a bunch of
chickens and cats it's a necessary evil
then it's a necessary evil yeah
what we need to do
is we need to build an ai
sentient humanoid robot construct that
is smart enough to start improving
itself and self-replicating that way it
eventually determines it doesn't need us
anymore wipes out all organic life and
then takes over the universe
you know who's gonna do that
bezos the octopi
why is that
the octopi is the most amazing thing on
this planet i believe that if octopi
lived longer than eight months or
whatever their lifespan is longer than
that
they could be like very old
oh
no
but they'd have a short life span and
they lived longer three to five years
there you go okay three to five years
it's not long right so i believe it
might be a certain species i was
thinking of but
i believed if they lived as long as
humans did we wouldn't be here they
would be the ones running this place you
know why they wouldn't be why no
combustion underwater
so this is this is the crazy thing about
technology is that a lot of our
capabilities like when you create a
computer
getting the finite uh like the
microprocessor getting all these little
tiny you know pathways and and
microchips and things like that
i i don't know if it's possible in a
water atmosphere in a water environment
so
if you want if you find a piece of ore
right
a rock and you can see there's iron in
it maybe other trace minerals
how do you separate them when you're
underwater what was the combustion for
so in an oxygen environment we can
create fire fire then melts down
minerals and separates the baser metals
and stuff we can then get the metal out
yeah so an octopus smart they're very
smart
and they have the ability to manipulate
you know fine-tune things but they can't
make fire so they can't manipulate well
they can crawl on land and they hold the
water in their heads and then eventually
it'll like squirt out the sides we
figured out how to keep the water inside
and come up when we came up on land and
then we just pee it out and drink it and
we keep the water in our bodies if they
could figure out how to store the water
and also if they could just crawl on
land and light a match i don't i
wouldn't put it past an octagon but they
can't move the way we can in this
environment
that's definitely true so maybe maybe
what would happen is they would they
would go up to the edge of water and
start fires on top and do their smelting
in the air atmosphere and then bring the
metals in to cool it and stuff i think i
think they would i think they would like
do you say what are they similar nervous
systems no they got like nine brains and
something like that yeah
yeah that's what i'm saying like
bro octopi are different
alien nine brains you're right
the octopuses indeed have nine brains
yeah they're so unique that it makes me
you know i'm gonna see them there's this
pan-spermic
invertebrates in the planet um where the
universe spit out like spores all across
the universe and they they can exist in
deep space spores and then they hit
planets and they sink into the water and
then they evolve into life as we know it
yeah and the different spores can evolve
into different things i don't know if
it's always got to be a spore
i think i think that if aliens came here
and
and and saw us in this idea of
combustion they'd laugh at us like you
guys are using combustion that's so uh
rudimentary that's so academic
we're on to uh oh you know like like the
chinese have the maglev right and i
think that's where the real secret is is
manipulating electricity and magnetism i
mean that's the question is how do you
refine elements without using fire why
are you refining elements because in
order to make a maglev train you need to
create a long track right so you need to
find the metals in the earth which are
randomly placed and mixed in with a
whole bunch of other minerals and you
need to shape it properly what if i
don't need a combustion to do that how
do you how do you shape metals how do
you extract the sound technology
how do you get the sound technology
how do you how do you get sound to emit
enough energy to so
mold together and shape metals so you
ever um
you ever seen the the experiment where
they play uh sound at a certain
frequency and glass shatters how do they
play the sound
at a very high pitch but but what's
making the sound some speaker i guess
what's the speaker made of
oh i guess you're going to come back to
some metal right see the thing is i can
take a tree smack it together and a fire
happens then i can put a rock over that
fire and the rock melts and i can
separate the metals out
then i can make a speed you could use so
that's what i'm saying so right like the
first person right they use fire and
then we go okay we don't need fire
anymore because we've created enough
these tools to liquefy things using
sound so like fire is for people who
haven't elevated our level yet right
right so yeah you used fire initially
and now that we've used fire to create
these sound technologies now we use
sound technology we don't need the fire
no more you see what i'm saying and then
now that was my theory on how they built
the pair it's like it's like we don't
need uh mud huts anymore right you know
right peop they're just taking wood and
it's like we don't need that we there
was a point where we did but now we're
well past that we have better
technologies and things like that yeah
we don't need we don't need the sticks
anymore to make the fire now we've got
spiders yeah oh and also you've got uh
plasma you know torches and things like
that right right we found other ways to
extract heat and apply heat to mold
things yeah yeah like acoustic
levitation have you studied that where
you vibrate something at a certain
frequency it starts to load like water
they'll do that in a vibrating in a
field yeah yeah that's what i think the
pyramids would build the pyramids were
cap well gold i wonder if they were if
lightning was hitting they were like
lightning rods and they were catching it
with water inside and then charging the
water and creating the large battery
doesn't make sense how so why would you
think that how would how would you hold
the charge of electricity in water
well you could store it in like a
vinegar or acid of some sort in a metal
rod
like a metal like the baghdad battery
but like a large one i don't think you
know
seven thousand do you know how batteries
work baghdad battery is a clay pot
filled with like vinegar with an iron
rod i think it's a copper rod copper rod
wrapped with iron wire or iron cord and
how does it generate a current and what
is a current
a current is electrons traveling along a
substrate so
if
the current from the lightning bolt goes
into the water
how does the current keep moving
yeah you need some sort of disc
discharge form to to have it move along
so like a watermelon wouldn't be a wire
or something well they could have i mean
there's no way the way it torches you
the ground wire
it is
the way batteries work is it's a
chemical process basically it's it's
it's not like there's energy
the energy captured is a chemical
process
and so when
i'm not
gonna
break down the finer points of anodes
and cathodes and all that stuff but it
creates an electron jumping over you
know between that's the current you're
getting
lightning striking something is not
creating a it's not you can't charge
things off lightning strikes because you
can't track the the voltage the amperage
the power of the lightning strike it's
unpredictable bro you haven't seen back
to the future before it doesn't work yes
it does no doctors went back into outer
space bro
[Laughter]
i thought back in time so when you when
when you're charging a battery you're
reversing the chemical process
and it has to be precise we need to know
how many amps there are so like when
we're hooking up the trailer it's a 50
amp outlet and then it's like you know
you've got if you've ever gone like
european countries and you're looking at
the outlet on the wall the weirdest
thing about europe is they have american
power outlets that are like 120 volts or
whatever
just for like shavers i guess but you
can plug your stuff and it works i
charge my phone off it anyway the point
is that wouldn't work um but the other
thing too is if you believe in modern
history we know how the pyramids were
built there's inner chambers they would
uh slide the
the blocks from the inside and they
would drop them one at a time going up
and then slowly going higher and higher
i guess the question is how did they
move the blocks dragging them in water
the moving isn't the isn't the hard part
well yeah water channels but also they
said that they loaded them the the lack
of mortar is the is the mystery well no
they just drop into place what do you
mean
but it's so like
keenly cut
like when they talk about like you can't
even fit a paper through they're still
trying to figure out how can you put the
bricks together i don't know they might
have had like a metal shaving unit that
was electric tapped to a bag that back
it was just like it hits it like that
and then i got a chisel real fine flat i
don't i don't think it's that
complicated you take a look at the you
ever see those statues in like ancient
rome or whatever it's like a woman's got
like she's she has a fishing net on her
um and the detail is so perfect you'd
assume she saw medusa or something like
how is how did they do the fishing net
so perfectly yeah because they just not
on
you know cut away at stuff and and take
water on a rag and just smooth things
out and it took a lot of work and took a
lot of time but the question is why are
there so many pyramids it was the
easiest thing to engineer stacking
blocks on top of each other and then all
you got to do is smooth them out that's
not hard you rub two rocks together
they're gonna start smoothing out
and then you're just ordinary human
ingenuity you know what i love
the like
absolute racism of ancient aliens
because they like they go to
central america and they're like how
could this giant rock have been moved
and then you see like the ancient
cultures and they're like well we can
move the rocks no no aliens aliens
certainly these humans could not have
figured out how to move giant rocks yeah
normally i don't jump to conclusions and
i'm pretty skeptical but when i look at
like roman technology you're talking
about the the fineness of the crafting
then you see all their their marble is
all white and it's like okay they didn't
just build white statues they painted
that stuff but the paint wore off so
what else is worn away that we don't see
no this is like i don't normally go down
these roads because i don't know but i
imagine that just assuming that they did
it with with stones and pieces of copper
is kind of like we know they had
batteries there's no fire marks in the
pyramids they didn't use torches in
there so they were using something to
light that it's not fire
and there's there are weird pictures
that appear to show like an object with
like beams of light coming out of it
yeah the arc might have been a battery
like a bag a large baghdad battery and
they said if you touched it it would
shot it would like hurt you so it might
have just been a massive current wow
and obviously that was ancient alien
technology that was left behind that
humans accidentally discovered
clearly yeah it's formed by the biden
administration that's right yeah see
biden is actually a
5 000 year old lizard no he's an octopus
from the moon
right now
the moon is actually the ark
and that's why it's always facing the
earth filled with vinegar that proves it
filled with vinegar you know about the
moon people you know about the moon
people there's people don't know about
the moon people there's people on the
moon that told us not to come back man
no yeah that's why nobody has been able
to do anything remotely successful with
the moon have you guys seen that movie
moon fall i was meant to watch it on a
flight how was that it's
really dumb is it i thought that's why i
didn't watch it i'm like yeah it's
probably good it's like stupid yeah it's
really dumb
you know
i'm gonna spoil a spoiler alert for
people seriously you don't want to hear
this if you plan on seeing the movie
because it's a big spoiler all right
five four three two one the moon is the
ark
and human civilization was from another
planet that was destroyed by an ai that
they created so then they escaped and
started building moons that would
terraform and create worlds for humans
to be reborn on
the ai destroyed muslim but one escaped
and it's our moon
and then the ai finds the moon and is
destroying it so the moon starts falling
to earth
so they go to the moon and then fight
the ai nanobots
and then like inside the moon of
spaceships get ready for like a million
i believe he's like that too i believe
that
you know what's weird i believe that is
closer to the truth than the pyramids
were built by aliens right they i
because you know they said that the well
they say the moon's hollow right if you
ping it or something they say it's
hollow so it's a spaceship i know that
that's what they think and so the idea
is the reason it looks rocky and
everything is because over you know the
billions of years it's collected dust
that's piled up
and so like
the idea in the movie was that the moon
was a spaceship that tariff gathered
mass and then created earth and then
seeded life on it and then eventually
seeded human life on it and now over
billions of years this giant metal
sphere got covered with dust and then
pelted with rocks and yes looks like
it's covered in rocks yeah one of my
ancestors has a face on the moon did you
see that did you see the face on the
moon yeah yeah well a long time that was
your that was your body that was one of
my ancestors that's cool yeah like they
just put their face like right in the
dust and then came back up and no it's
actually the opposite
what one of my ancestors was buried on
the moon he was a giant and his face is
like sticking out of it if you google
face on the moon you'll see his face pop
up and yeah he looks just like me
because there's no wind erosion so it
just yeah it's just there yeah what gets
me is how all these planets have the
moons but we have the moon
like we have thumb on yeah see there it
goes that's the face mode that's one of
my aunts it's not a very normal moon
this yeah this guy right here oh no not
that not not that guy
no not that one that that one right this
one right here yeah that's that's my
ancestor you know that's just people
just see faces you know what i mean do
they they do i think we may have evolved
to look like this because we stared out
into space and we've we've become what
we see
you see like every once in a while you
see like this weird cosmicological uh
image of like an eye it looks like an
eyeball like with like the fibers going
out but you see it's like a supernova or
like a quasar or something but he's
actually like in our family tree like
we've traced back our lineage to the
moon people that's why i know about the
moon people i'm not supposed to tell you
this
do you think there are hollow earth
people
well that's where the the the command
center is
no no inside the center of the moon not
the earth what i know about halloween
not the earth the earth no that's that's
the biden people the earth is flat
and hollow like a donut and in the
middle is where the illuminati is dude
it's the helix nebula you got to look
this
it's called the helix nebula
okay uh-oh eyeballs you want to say
looking at a human eyeball look at this
thing maybe there are more than one
helix nebulae out there but this is like
this is what an eyeball looks like i
mean what's the definition of a nebula
again wasn't it like an exploded galaxy
or exploded
black
a network what is it again a nebula
planetary nebula double helix nebula
distinct body of interstellar
is it post-explosion or ionized gas
ejected from a red giant star
yes okay yes so it's the et's post
explosion to answer your question mary
yeah i think there are people living in
the hollow earth
i think that earth because what there's
this planet thea this theory that like i
know it's four billion years ago when
they're basically when the u when the
solar system was formed all these the
sun ejaculated all this rock and just
spit like 28 planetoids out they started
smashing into each other one of them
went through earth came out the other
end and cooled down and became the moon
but if that really happened and the
planet collided with us then we're not
solid on the inside there's going to be
fractures and rips and openings and
tears so
to say that there's no life down there
would be insane and insane in the
interior of the earth yeah
whether or not it's humans i don't
aren't they called something
dinosaurs
the conspiracy theory is that um
dinos lizard people live in in the earth
deep deep deep underground because there
was a very intelligent species of
species of dinosaur and then when the
the meteor or whatever came down and
wiped everybody out they escaped
underground and survived and they can't
survive on the surface because they've
developed they've uh adapted to a low
light environment so the sun would cause
damage to them so that's why eight
stories beneath the denver airport is
the the it's the port between the
surface world where we are and the
lizard people world where they are now
we can go down there we just need
instruments to see better but they can't
come up here so they have to rule from
the shadows what do they eat
psilocybin that's why they're so
intelligent
[Laughter]
so let me get this straight there are
lizard people eight stories beneath the
earth and they only eat mushrooms
and they're just tripping you don't have
much hunger when you're when you're on
mushrooms some people do think there are
feral cannibals uh living in our
national parks
yo you know people live underground in
new york
this is true story so the lizard stuff
obviously screwing around but in new
york there are people who live in the
old subway tunnels oh yeah this is true
so uh
during this like occupy protest in grand
central some woman apparently came up
and she was like she was like hey what's
going on they're like oh there's a
protest and they were like you got to
get out of here because the cops are
going to find us and they go underground
and they live in the underground tunnels
genius like under the subway in the old
old tunnels and like under under under
them yeah it's vegas too i think your
theory about uh cataclysm on the surface
forcing lizards to go underground it's
not not my theory i don't actually think
that's true but it's a good it's i just
i just weird
if it's funny because where would they
go either they're all gonna die or
they're gonna go underground well that's
demolition man right like demolition man
had the people living underground
demolition man yeah the movie that's
sylvester stallone no well there were
people they weren't lizards but they
were people forced to live underground
oh right right right right yeah and i
think that's where the future's headed
like if you're a conservative republican
you're going to live in the sewers and
frankie toobin says i'm not drunk enough
for the show tonight when you lose one
sense that your other senses become more
powerful so maybe as their vision dips
their sixth sense an ability to mind
manipulate their surroundings has
advanced yo i gotta read this one
me says whoa parts of this conversation
is what happens when you roll 18 for
intelligence and three for wisdom yeah i
love playing characters like that
nailed it all right we gotta go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show head over
to timcast.com become a member support
our work let's read what y'all have to
say
all right dominic camarada says i still
remember you breaking down the slave
theory on jre with artifacts being
located from az to the hills in ohio it
makes you wonder
what's that what was that yeah what was
that well they basically try to say that
black people are the descendants of
slaves and i'm like nah we were here we
are the natives and the people who claim
to be natives are culturally
appropriating us
what is that like like native americans
yeah the native americans are black
people from africa like the atlantis
culture their their skin would have been
darker tone because they had so much sun
then north african culture they could
have easily populated the americas yeah
i mean all you got to do is read the
letter from um d saint and no no from
christopher columbus to descent angel
and he'll tell you all about it
all right ginger jack says tim are you
still are you still opening that comic
game store i need a venue that won't
pull authoritarian nonsense on me so i
can run a dnd game or vampire larp to
network in best virginia before moving
we found a building
we're going to open a skate shop
venue game store
so we're going to have skate stuff we're
going to have all the stuff you'll need
probably it's even big enough to
actually have an area to skate so maybe
in the winter there's like a ledge and a
rail sign a waiver pay a couple bucks
come in hang out have fun but then we'll
also we're also going to have gaming
cards probably do magic yu-gi-oh what
else pokemon whatever vampire the
masquerade he was saying you guys ever
played that one oh yeah dnd i played um
things like it what are your favorite
character types to play
um let's see
um
mutants uh i like i like mutants did you
play aberrant
nah i played um was it heroes legend of
heroes
um
i forget what it was but it's very
similar you roll your character to
figure out you know we're gonna do all
that it's gonna be fun yeah mutants are
nice it's gonna be fun and we're
planning on doing like uh family family
gathering saturday mornings
where we
the idea is to do saturday morning
cartoons okay because they don't really
exist anymore right do an event where we
have like breakfast for parents the
parents can hang out do mimosas or
bloody mary's or whatever but the kids
can watch
like approved cartoons that families
think are okay and then just meet your
neighbors hang out build community all
that good stuff ducktales ducktales
there you go ducktales or you know to be
honest we'll watch uh you know chip
chill or whatever it's called the daily
wires launching
you know we'll watch some of that
ducktales was
was my dream i mean scrooge just the
character arc built into the man
just uh he he's my real uncle yeah it
was i i learned it in relation you can't
dive into gold for real because you'll
it'll crush your skull
i've burned so many brain cells trying
to figure out how that was possible
all right jeffrey max says tim please
create teaser trailers for your member
podcast for example a short clip from
last night's show of ian cussing about
biden believe it and it would get people
signing up add more bleeps for comic
effect
we could do that we got a lot of stuff
in the works man um it just takes a long
time to do everything so right now
we're working on a piece of critical
infrastructure which is going to be a
huge announcement hopefully next week
taking a while then we've got to start
designing
everything the goal is uh smart tv apps
phone apps
hopefully by this time next year
you will be as a member at timcast.com
pulling up the app and seeing a bunch of
different shows
and we're going for to start
lower budget authenticity because
it's really what we can afford but i'm
really excited for tales for the
inverted world these episodes are like
45 minutes to an hour long of breaking
down this real investigation true
stories of this uh shane cashman who
went down to georgia looking for the
lost confederate gold
someone threatened to kill him skin him
alive
creepy stuff it's like hunter s thompson
meets the x-files but we're also going
to be doing a talk show with him once a
week so not only do you get the full
season which is going to be like 13
episodes you'll then get a weekly show
of more of a podcast talk show
in a creepy setting we're building a
studio in a haunted house we're doing
such cool stuff hopefully within the
next five years we're going to have our
own game of thrones we're going to have
our own movies and we'll be doing all
that really cool stuff so i'm really
excited for that we got a lot of work to
do
all right let's grab some more super
chats
t-craft says happy friday let's change
the world one podcast at a time you know
it oh yeah yeah i really we have we have
a potentially like a self-help show kind
of thing you know we got some we got
some cool stuff in the works man it's
gonna be fun you guys know what kymatics
are no what's that it's cymatics yeah
cymatics yeah it's how sound uh what the
deal is they put like salt on a on a
vibrating membrane and then they'll
change the frequency of the vibration
and then you'll see the salt will like
change form there's videos of it on
youtube it's really cool and i was
talking to ben stewart and i was like i
had a horrible depression from like 2009
to 2017 and he was like maybe it's like
climatics like as a human species we
were in that state of chaos i mean we
still may be coming out of it and kind
of reforming talking about changing the
world with a podcast
or masa imodo he he was one of the
pioneers in in some of the cymatic work
oh cool we talked about that guy last
week i think yeah all right we got dv
velasco says hi tim from arizona just
became a member yesterday i had to hear
the after hours segment with carrie lake
for whom i'm voting for governor love
the show great guests and discussions
if you're you guys should check this one
out uh carrie lake we talked about the
election we talked about 2020. we talked
about what she wants to do and what she
thinks happened and if you want to hear
about all that timcast.com is up right
now on the on the home page
check it out check it out become a
member uh i really want to you know
i'll say this the more shows we produce
the less money we make per show right
obviously it costs money to put a video
up and have you watch it and if we give
you know 50 shows for 10 bucks a month
the same thing then we're spending way
more money deliver content we're making
way less
but hopefully more people then sign up
and we can keep expanding and expanding
the margins get smaller and smaller but
volume increases so you eventually make
more money and then the goal ultimately
for me what i want to see is
good content fun shows honest
conversations and pushing back on how
the corporate culture has started
expanding how wokeness has infected
everything the daily wires doing their
thing as well so i'm a huge fan we have
a slightly different corporate culture
and vibe than they do but we agree on
tons as a huge overlap some you know
similar to what they're doing but with a
different style as it were
so all right let's read some more nest b
says hotep jesus needs to bring uncle
hotep with him next time you guys rock
oh thank you yeah that's the yeah we
gotta do that absolutely
that's the homie shot uncle hotel
all right sergeant mango garcias as i
normally listen to friday's show on
mondays got on just to leave the super
chat factory fires are common
catastrophic damage that impacts
production is not common small fires are
often put out before things get bad
interesting
they probably have massive protocol in
those facilities for that too
that are probably hard to miss
pardaxilla says mary is an all-star keep
her on irl
thank you very much well we'll have her
on every so often you know she got to
host her own show got a pop culture
crisis to deal with
michael says tim joe biden may be on
meth you can be prescribed
methamphetamine under the brand name
disoxen is that true
look that up
ian pull that up
desoxin oral
what is it what's the uh chemical
composition is it meth
yeah
well it says so reddit says it is yeah
adhd medicine oh yeah read it definitely
all right beastly devil says tim i just
watched a reaction channel watching the
season finale of the boys and they were
reeling over the final minutes of said
finale as as it conflates the crowd's
behavior to a maga crowd
yo have you guys watched the boys
i have not yes i've seen a little bit i
loved the ending of the last episode um
i don't should i spoil it yeah all right
i'm gonna spoil it heads up i am going
to spoil it warning warning warning i'm
trying to be as nice as possible spoiler
alert for the last episode of the boys
all right now
you know what it's about right no so uh
it's like it's supposed to be a mockery
of superhero shows not really a mockery
but like it's a more real version of
what superheroes would be like like
reality
and so it's a it's basically the justice
league homelander he's basically
superman he's got laser vision he can
fly uh the deep is basically aquaman and
maeve is basically wonder woman but
they're all just like such awful people
so homelander they basically made into
trump
so they decided to just roll with it he
was like dating a nazi and it's like
it's really dumb um but the end of uh
you guys spoiler alert
mute it because here it comes
what's happened is at the uh homelander
accuses starlight another superhero of
trafficking children and they make it
sound like you know hillary and he's
trump
but like he's lying he's lying to you
and they have a guy's a tv show to
basically tucker carlson they're like
it's all lies
and then you end up with
the me a me too crowd who are like save
maeve me to hashtag me too and then a
bunch of people
saying like you know
shut up snowflake signs and like they're
big into homelander
in the end
homelander spoiler spoiler here comes
homelander is introducing his son to the
crowd of the patriots or whatever they
call he calls him his patriots or
whatever
and then a leftist wearing a me too
shirt throws a bottle and hits his son
in the face
and then homelander just snaps and blows
his head up and then all the patriot
people look and then one guy goes
yeah
yeah
yeah and they'll go yeah now they're
cheering for him having murdered a
leftist and i just thought it was
hilarious i was like oh my god that's on
tv that's on tv these people are just
like the show was trying to emulate
what's going on now
in a self-aware way
no no i mean it is actually kind of
funny the way they depict everything but
they really do try to make trump the bad
guy
but like
they then jump way beyond where we are
now showing the trumpian character just
murdering a leftist activist like in
cold blood in front of everyone and they
cheer for it and i'm just like
yo these people lost their minds this is
crazy if you could have one superpower
what would you have
i don't know man um
define what you mean by one superpower
you only get one you don't get two like
you can't fly and shoot lasers
oh i love doctors but he can do a lot of
power that's cheating yeah no he's one
superhero his power is the mystic arts i
would stop at time
other than mike exactly that's the
perfect one time manipulation yeah not
that makes no sense because
i already thought like a million things
in that moment when you pause because i
stopped you fast
he has all the responses so what happens
when you when you move
with time stopped well like silver it's
you can never truly stop time i can
always slow it down right then i would
slow everything else to a very very
small and then you would disintegrate
now i'd move through it like a
slipstream that would you made my hero
too and then what would you do with that
move people around save people go places
they would explode what would you do
with the bible explode friction
no but i like things because i can slip
through it but other people would so we
tried if if somebody if you if you were
super fast like quicksilver or the flash
and you walked up to someone and moved
their arm you would see their their skin
would stay
there's atmospheric friction so if you
make if you tap them and make them move
you'd see like their skin ripple and
start to get ripped yeah but he has the
superpower for that none of those
reactions that's right other people i
can i can move it all around but he but
he can manipulate it that's like part of
it that's multiple superpowers come on
slow and stop time this would be my
ideal for other people and myself so if
i needed to move you through it with me
i could what would you would you always
thought that was you can't pick the same
your clothes disappear too
that's
i can make people's clothes disappear
what is it about doctor strange that
entices you because he can do anything
doctor strange is the most powerful
you can't name a hero but what would be
your power
mastery of the mystic arts
it's hardcore dude defined
what about you brian
dr strange can control the source code
of the universe
can he really yes
yep can someone else like control it
against him with the same abilities
that's when they fight right like when
they're fighting they're
you know that's what uh uh in the movie
that's what the yeah what was that
called uh the movie that came doctors
the new doctor strange multiverse
but in the first one she says they're
spells but if that offends your modern
sensibilities you can call it a program
he's basically writing universal
programs so you can write a program to
execute in the universe you could do
whatever you wanted yeah when the
infinity gauntlet fell into the hands of
thanos adam warlock went to doctors he's
like i need to contact a human strange
as the guy adrian curry says i'd be dr
manhattan hands down yo it's a legit
power but
his his attachment to reality is
fractured because he can see forward and
backwards in time
i don't know how he keeps it together i
don't know let's read some more super
chats good question though
all right what do we got going on anyway
yeah check out the i think the boys is
great miss marvel's a terrible show it's
even worse i okay go off remember when i
complained about how they won't shut up
about partition
okay the latest episode is literally
just like a partition documentary i'm
like you're still watching i turned it
off
and what's participation when when they
uh in india and i learned this from
watching ms marvel the the british
separated india into pakistan and india
to move the muslims into pakistan and
everyone else and then it created a
whole bunch of problems and that's what
they told that's what they taught me and
then she goes back in time
for somehow some reason she miss marvel
goes back in time and now she's like in
partition and now it's just about two
characters experiencing partition and
i'm like um
yeah i kind of wanted to see a girl who
could make her hand really big punch a
bank robber
i didn't want to learn about british
colonial history you phrased it you're
like the boys is great and miss miss
marvel is even worse like do you mean
great like it's so bad it's good it's
it's
i actually really like the boys
and and and the the
politicizing of it is so bad it's
hilarious
but
i think carl urban he's the billy the
butcher it's a he's a great character oh
yeah he's from star trek from that star
trek movie he's in the lord of the rings
yeah yeah so i just thought that that
like the boys is a good it's worth
watching but the political stuff is just
so hammed up oh man
all right let's see we got here
we'll grab some more super chats i was
listening to a movie once and i heard
them like sound bite in
it's trump's fault i think it was uh
uh the movie uh something something in
slim where the two the black couple like
uh kill a cop or something now they're
on the run and i heard him put a sound
bite in because some cop killed a boy in
the movie they're like it's trump's
fault i'm like yo yo i just inserted a
sound bite
queen and slim queen and slim there you
go yeah
it's like wow like they put it in the
movie sometimes stamped up political
stuff can be funny like get out
like
that's yeah that's different that's
funny it's hilarious but yeah i just
don't like when they do it like that you
like i pay attention to the insertions
and like in between a scene change it
just says it's trump's fault and i'm
like i heard that
are you not supposed to hear it or is it
like it's very quick and subliminal it's
supposed to be like edging you to not
like trump and it's like this has
nothing it's a movie it's a fictional it
has nothing to do with trump like how
does that even end up in there
this is all right i wonder whether like
movies should acknowledge that covet
happened all right the chronicles of
chris says
another fun fact about communism to add
to hotep's wisdom capitalism is actually
financial communism read the
libertarianism.org article should
libertarians abandon the word capitalism
yeah i've said that in the past because
they're the ones that popularized it
capitalism is definitely a socialist
word
all right stephen bachmeier says tim i
will subscribe to tim cast when you have
an actual bible scholar on it's
exhausting listening to roman
conspiracies and wrong history history
mike winger inspiring philosophy
us guinness anyone hmm i mean we're not
suggestions in mind
yeah
i love listening to biblical scholars
you know we should do we should get like
a i have an idea
we'll do a members only segment with a
theologian and biblical scholar talking
to ian
you got to get it you should have scott
hahn
have scott han on the show no you got to
do a hebrew israelite if you want to
break the internet
you know about the hebrew israelites
yes yeah you want to break the internet
get somebody like captain tazar yacht on
crash
sweet i'm down let's uh you so we're
talking about uh other shows we can do
obviously this show is
it's not like uh rogan you know
rogan sits down with one on one and just
talks yeah we're topical news with a
guest right right right so it's like we
have the crew we have our the guest who
comes in and we mix a little of their
world with the comments which is
brilliant yeah and then we're thinking
about what we could do for like sunday
shows
figuring out a way to film is hard
because i already work 16 hours monday
through friday and then saturday and
sunday is when i can do like
administrative stuff but uh we were
thinking about doing like
deep debates and heavy conversations as
a members only show
that or i should i shouldn't call it
microzone anymore because we're
expanding it just be like website
exclusives but uh one of the ideas could
be
having like a a black hebrew israelite
with like uh uh um a rabbi um
damn you going that hard jesus
oh my god i love that man i love that
yeah or i think i think we could easily
get started by having like a biblical
scholar talk to ian
yeah just do a conversation i think it
would be fascinating i think you would
be intelligent respectful and very like
homie chad's brother i interviewed him
he's a he's one of those guys it's like
uh
uh evan lemoine he he does uh
uh
sexual consultation with christians who
think that having sex is bad and against
a bible and he's like no this is good
and you're allowed to copulate and so on
and so forth yeah
i like this black hebrew israelite thing
i've never really heard much about it oh
it's amazing such a yeah so
the belief that the israelite north
african descendants
of israel yeah that makes a lot of sense
yeah all right let's uh let's grab a
couple more here what do we got here
liberty or death says there is no
physical description of jesus in the
bible he was born to a judean mother in
a backwater town in israel we can guess
at his ethnic appearance but that's not
important he's the savior he was born
into the essenian community
and i wouldn't call it backwater
jesus was upper middle class upper
middle class upper middle class he lived
a good life
oh yeah they tried to say oh he was born
in a manger and he was poor and now he's
born in the essenian community
e-s-s-e-n-i-a-n or something like that
all right we got oscar who says my
father always told me of his time in
cuba there was no stress no worry about
the hustle and bustle they had to work
hard but they just spent time with
family and enjoyed life until the
communists came around yup
and then people got really upset about
it
yeah
dim sum nimsom says harrison bergeron
read the book or watch the movie
dystopia where government actively makes
people average also rome was in brittany
and close to france white jesus is very
possible
yeah rome got all the way up there in
england at some point to hadrian's wall
hadrian i think that was the roman
emperor yeah built that wall between
england and scotland because you
couldn't conquer the scots man they have
too many mountains
yeah yeah
yeah
sparky says octopi could develop a
different tech paradigm ah that's what i
was thinking about like maybe they could
go down to like volcanic events
and then
use
something to like water weapons yeah
they just and if you could neural net
their brains if they have nine brains
yeah
imagine just walking down the street and
just
all of a sudden you get hit with a water
balloon
damn goddamn octopi it's begun
you can
why are you giving these people ideas
that's going to lead to our demise doing
it to like chimps right yes
yes
but not the octopi i'm scared we would
need them to uh can nine extra brains to
test on yeah condone it is that the
right word yellow fluffy feather says
tim you need a call-in show
we're talking about it uh here's a
challenge i can only do so much you know
it's like i do a morning show it takes
like eight hours i do the nightly show
which takes a little bit less time
timcast irl works because i spend all
day reading the news for my morning show
and then i just read hundreds of
articles every day it's kind of
ridiculous or i should say i skimmed
through hundreds of articles and then
read a couple dozen do that every day
do what every day do you do that every
day when you work every day
people have to understand is once you
get to tim pool's level you can do
anything so it's like you have to look
through the list of anything and go okay
i'll pick and do this right because
anybody can do anything well yes exactly
but tim cool could do yeah but you could
like pay to fly people to a place and
have a building erected and like that
level of like financial success and
freedom yeah he can he can so but it
becomes harder because there's things
that you know people come to me
why haven't you done this i'm like i can
do a lot of different things it's just
like what do i want to do out of all of
this list of things you can do and that
goes like you said any it goes for
anybody anybody can learn anything it's
like but what are you going to learn
what are you going to build i think
we're we're really close
to um i should say really close but when
the preliminary stages of doing this
sunday special show the special sunday
show which is going to be like debates
it's going to be like debates
so for example having a religious
scholar on talk with ian or something is
kind of the idea to bring people of like
different world views to sit down and
talk about these things and the question
what we're asking right now is moderated
or unmoderated moderated do you think
moderated absolutely i would moderate it
if you want if you don't want to but uh
because
what we don't want is like if we get a
communist and a capitalist to them start
yelling at each other yes the yelling
is that's what we're aiming for is like
content like so information so not
getting culture warriors getting
scholars so you'll get someone who's
like well read on marks in communist
literature to be like yes yes yes i know
i know but what you're forgetting is in
the capital sky can be like when you
look at every example and then end with
a handshake and be like man that was
crazy yeah or have like an atheist talk
with a religious scholar but i've got to
be honest like in these examples i'll
tell you my bias
the communist scholar is going to be
smart they're going to know a lot about
communism and the capitalist is going to
run circles around them or the
libertarian you do an atheist and a
theologian
and the theologian is going to run
circles around them yeah like people who
who who's
i'll just put it as my bias you know
based on the things i've read and and my
experiences i've seen so many people who
uh
like on the left
don't know anything about economics uc
has a degree and she doesn't even know
capitalism means yeah or she's lying
yeah and then you talk to people who are
atheists and they're like i've not
actually read any of this and i don't
know any about it and it's like okay so
you're an atheist i get it that's fine
but how can you argue against something
you didn't actually read you don't even
know what you're arguing against yeah so
maybe it wouldn't be ian maybe it would
be uh
no ian's good because he got the hippie
weird dmt view of the world
so having him talk with a religious
scholar would be really interesting and
i can admit i'm pretty good at listening
i don't necessarily i'm kind of ignorant
about a lot of stuff but i i can listen
to two people talk and if they start to
miscommunicate i can see why and then
enlighten them where they're each
missing and then kind of get it back i
can teach econ and really fast right so
there's two types of econ you got econ
101 which is must be taught and you must
go to thomas seoul but econ 201 is a
really short course it basically says
don't touch anything
all right let's uh
grab a couple more here
yoshida said my power would be called
save point it's the power to go back and
relive my life over and over again while
retaining my knowledge constantly
learning but could you say
could you stay good because you do
wouldn't you do evil things if you could
just go back like could you stay sane if
you were conscious when you're playing
skyrim and then like the bartender says
something mean and you go like save f5
yeah
quick save
yeah you see what happens if i just
head off oh that happens okay let me go
back to that save point that's a good
power uh save state
that's really good you could you could
save a state in time
and then always jump back to it if you
wanted but what if you needed a friend a
load state so you guys had to work
together forever well that's not good
power super power yeah but if you could
if you had like
you could save an endless number of
states and just place it wherever you
wanted and then you could like pull up
the chart and look at every different
save point and be like i'm going to go
back i'm going to go back to when i was
looking
my boss at burger king would be a safe
point for me it's like you know what
what'd you just say save
do over do over do over dover
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait how old were you hold on 16
years half inader says never take time
travel power before you know it you'll
go back to do something altruistic but
somehow accidentally cause your mom to
fall in love with you instead of your
dad and thus erase yourself from
existence
but save state is only within your
timeline so i'm gonna be like see that
see el toro el toro famous 20 stair
handrail for those i don't know i'm
going to do a 360 flip i'm gonna do a
big flip back nosebleed
and then you save state and you go for
it and then right as you're falling you
just load state right back up at time
you're like i'm going to keep doing
until i get it first try exactly
adrian curry says you could save your
loved ones from cancer with a save point
you'd know it was coming to warn them
and they develop a stronger kind of
cancer
all right let's grab one more we got
jabba chew says i'm i'm a big fan of the
channel guys thanks for doing what y'all
do i live in maine and we all just got
850 worth of printed money so i thought
i'd share some with you guys well all
right
my friends we are going to sit in deep
thought about which superpowers we want
and then how to attain them so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com if you would like to fund
our mission to become superheroes i'm
just kidding that's not going to happen
but you can help support the development
of content and culture and we really do
appreciate it my goal is not to be
saying help us build a build build a
mission or
fulfill the mission but hopefully with
the next several months we'll just be
saying more of we have a ton of shows to
offer you please consider buying them
that's what it's all about free market
solutions so become a member at
timcast.com smash the like button follow
us at tim cast irl follow me at tim cast
hotep you want to shout anything out
uh i say things on youtube subscribe to
my youtube channel hotep jesus uh if you
like it uh stick around if you don't
like it please don't be mean to me
because people are so
mean on the internet
that's all i got
if you want to see me more often you
should go follow me on instagram or
wechat at closer kitty
and i also demand that you go find pop
culture crisis on youtube and subscribe
we go live at 3 p.m eastern and noon
pacific time every monday through friday
and i expect to see you there on monday
in the chat
uh i am ian crosslin you follow me in
crossland.net get in touch with me on
social media through that and one time i
woke up and i saw my phone was in front
of me and i saw infrared light and it
looked like i felt my mind bend and the
light went into the flick as i lost the
perceptive capability that it looked
like the light was like going in if i
was just losing it but you can see in
for you can become a mutant of sorts if
you want superheroing is not out of the
question you're all right thank you guys
for tuning in to this fun night with
hotep jesus you always know with this
gentleman it is going to be a spicy
evening you guys can follow me on
twittermines.com at sourpatchlids as
well as sourpatchlets.me
check out cast castle go to
youtube.comcastcastle watch our silly
shenanigans show we've got jamie
kilstein who's helping he's been writing
jokes and we're trying to make a
semi-fictionalized version of everything
that goes on here because we're making
more and more content and then we've
also got another big plane in the works
with free damastan where we're going to
be doing action sports kind of
shenanigans with skateboarding scooters
bikes rollerblades probably baseballs
basketballs and other craziness so check
it all out
youtube.comcastcastle thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you